I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey.
We were on The Office together and we're best friends.
And now we're doing the ultimate Office Lovers podcast just for you.
Each week we will dive deeper into the world of the office with exclusive interviews
behind the scenes details and lots of BFF stories.
We're the Office Lady 6.0.
Hi there.
Hi.
我是珍娜·菲舍尔，我是安吉拉·金西。我们曾一起出演《办公室》，而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你带来这档终极的《办公室》爱好者播客。每周我们都会深入探讨《办公室》的世界，分享独家采访、幕后细节以及大量闺蜜故事。我们是“办公室女郎 6.0”。大家好。嗨。
Welcome to today's episode that is in honor of Angela's birthday.
It's my birthday week.
It's your birthday week.
You are surrounded by presents and balloons and sweet treats.
Sam and I both went balloons this year.
Skip flowers.
I know.
They're beautiful and festive, and I thank you.
欢迎收看今天的节目，这是为了庆祝安吉拉的生日。这是我的生日周。这是你的生日周。你被礼物、气球和甜点包围了。今年我和萨姆都准备了气球。不要花。我知道。它们又漂亮又喜庆，我谢谢你们。
And is this a box of donuts?
Lady, it is a box of donuts.
Yeah!
Because I was like, listen, you are married to a man who can make you the best cake or pie or whatever.
And I thought, what is a sweet?
treat that you love that Josh does not make for you, and it's donuts. That's right. So I did check in
with him. I wanted to make sure I knew your favorite. Did you get just like, I'm a basic bitch. It's just
glazed. That's it. It's glazed. Sam. Yep, that's very you. Thank you. It's a very on brand.
这是不是一盒甜甜圈？女郎，这就是一盒甜甜圈。耶！因为我想，听着，你嫁给了一个能为你做最好的蛋糕、派或任何东西的男人。我想，什么是你喜欢而乔希不会为你做的甜食，那就是甜甜圈。没错。所以我向他确认过。我想确保我知道你最喜欢哪种。你是不是只拿了那种，我就是个俗人。就是糖霜的。没错。就是糖霜的。萨姆。是的，非常符合你的风格。谢谢。非常有个人特色。
Yeah. So that's from my local donut shop that I love. Oh, I love a local donut shop.
Give it to me. I love one, too, where you go in and it's like donuts, or would you
like a burrito. I'm like, okay. Oh, yeah. You know what I mean? Sure. And then it's like, also,
we have some egg rolls. Fine. Great. Yep. Give it all to me. This is just donuts. I'm fine with that.
I'm just saying, I love a local donut shop. Well, listen, lady, you planned such a fantastic
birthday episode for me this year. You set the bar pretty high. So I hope you like what we've planned.
It's already off to a great start. Okay, good, good. There's donuts. Well, everyone,
in the episode, Angela's going to answer the call sheet questions. I'm very excited for that.
是的。所以那是来自我喜欢当地甜甜圈店。哦，我很喜欢当地的甜甜圈店。把它给我。我也很喜欢那种你走进去，然后老板说，这是甜甜圈，还是你想要个卷饼。我就想，好吧。哦，是啊。你知道我的意思吗？当然。然后又说，我们还有一些春卷。好吧。太棒了。耶。全给我吧。这里只有甜甜圈。我完全可以接受。我只是说，我很喜欢当地的甜甜圈店。好吧，听着，女郎，今年你为我策划了一期如此精彩的生日节目。你把标准定得挺高的。所以我希望你喜欢我们策划的内容。它已经有了一个很好的开端。好吧，很好，很好。有甜甜圈。好了，各位，在节目中，安吉拉将回答通告单上的问题。对此我非常兴奋。
But, you know, at the top of my birthday episode, we had a really fun dish session. We talked about
going to the SAG Awards. Yeah. And I thought, I feel like we need a fun dish session for your birthday, too.
But then I was like, is there a fun story that we have not told on the podcast? I mean,
after all these years, it's getting slim. It is. I feel like we've reported everything. Everything.
But, you know, Jenna, you had a theme for your birthday, which really helped me when I was shaping your episode.
You said books and fabulous women.
And so I was able to latch on to that, but that got me thinking, if I was to set a theme for my birthday, I think it would be family, friends, and tennis.
Because those are three things I want to spend more time enjoying.
但是，你知道，在我生日节目的开头，我们有一个非常有趣的闲聊环节。我们谈到了去参加美国演员工会奖。Yeah. 我觉得，你的生日我们也需要一个有趣的闲聊环节。但后来我想，有没有什么有趣的故事是我们没有在播客里讲过的？我的意思是，经历了这么多年的节目，选择越来越少了。确实如此。我觉得我们已经把所有事情都报道了。所有事情。但是，你知道，珍娜，你为你的生日设定了一个主题，这在我构思你的节目时真的帮了大忙。你说的是书籍和杰出的女性。所以我能够抓住这一点，但这让我开始思考，如果我要为我的生日设定一个主题，我想那会是家庭、朋友和网球。因为这是我想要花更多时间去享受的三件事。
And then I was going through old photos, and I found some from our time on family feud with our sisters and your mom.
And I know we mentioned this years ago, you know, on the podcast when we went on the actual game show,
but lady, we never really dish.
You know what I mean?
We never really got down to it.
Well, you tell me your theme.
You told me this idea.
And I said, I love it.
然后我翻看旧照片，发现了一些我们带着姐妹和你的妈妈一起上《家庭问答》时的照片。我知道我们几年前在播客里提到过这件事，当时我们去参加了真正的游戏节目，但女郎，我们从来没有真正八卦过。你知道我的意思吗？我们从来没有深入聊过。好吧，你告诉我你的主题。你把这个想法告诉了我。我说，我太喜欢了。
Let's dish.
Okay.
First, I think we need to explain how it all came about.
And Jenna, if my memory serves, didn't you get an email from the folks at Family Feud saying, like,
would your family like to go on and, like, compete for a charity?
Yeah, that's right.
They asked me if I might like to go on with some of my office co-stars or my family.
我们来八卦一下吧。我们来八卦一下。好的。首先，我觉得我们需要解释这一切是怎么开始的。珍娜，如果我的记忆没出错的话，是不是《家庭问答》的工作人员给你发了一电子邮件，说，比如，你的家人想不想来参加并为一个慈善机构竞争？是的，没错。他们问我是否愿意和我的《办公室》搭档或者我的家人一起去。
They kind of said, build a team.
And I thought it would be really fun since your sister is a teacher and my mom is a teacher
and my sister is also a teacher.
I thought that we could all go on together and we could play for adoptaclassroom.org.
I mean, that's a win-win.
I was so excited.
And for those of you guys that are unfamiliar, adopta classroom is an amazing national nonprofit
that connects people who can donate to help out pre-K through 12th grade educators to provide funding
他们某种程度上说，组建一个团队。我想，既然你姐姐是一名老师，我妈妈是一名老师，我姐姐也是一名老师，我们大家一起去参加并为 adoptaclassroom.org 战队玩游戏会非常有趣。我的意思是，这是一个双赢的局面。我太兴奋了。对于你们当中不熟悉的人来说，Adopta Classroom 是一个了不起的国家级非营利组织，它将能够捐款的人联系起来，帮助学前班到12年级的教育工作者提供资金
for school supplies. And their goal is to help teachers from having to spend their own money
on essential learning materials for their classroom. Well, this was really cool because we got
to do something fun with our family members and also honor their years of teaching. But we only
got the money if we won. We got like a little bit of money for our charity just for showing up,
but we wanted the big dollars. That's right. Oh, and also,
So wait, we have to talk about the fact that the minute we said yes, we all then got on a text
thread because we had to coordinate outfits.
Yes.
用于学校用品。他们的目标是帮助老师们不必自己掏钱购买教室里的基本学习材料。这真的很酷，因为我们和家人一起做了一件有趣的事情，同时也向他们多年的教学生涯致敬。但我们只有赢了才能拿到钱。我们仅仅因为出场就为我们的慈善机构拿到了一点点钱，但我们想要大笔资金。没错。哦，还有，等等，我们必须聊聊这件事：我们一说好，大家就立刻拉了一个短信群，因为我们需要协调服装。是的。
They suggest that you coordinate your outfits.
Like if you watch Family Feuds, some people get like whole like special sweatshirts made and all
that, but we didn't have time.
So we came up with, get ready for this guys.
Blouse with black slacks.
Fancy blouse with black slacks.
And we tried to all do the same color blouse.
if you remember.
他们建议你协调服装。就像如果你看过《家庭问答》，有些人会定制整套的特别运动衫之类的，但我们没有时间。所以我们想出了一个主意，大家准备好听这个。衬衫配黑色长裤。漂亮的衬衫配黑色长裤。而且我们尽量穿同一种颜色的衬衫。如果你还记得的话。
But we couldn't find a color that we all had.
Your mom and I had kind of a green color.
Yeah.
You had sort of like a pink.
Your sister was like a reddish pink.
And then my sister Janet was blue.
Well, because we settled on jewel tones.
Yes.
但我们找不到一个我们所有人都有的颜色。你妈妈和我有一种偏绿的颜色。是的。你穿的是有点像粉红色的。你姐姐穿的是那种红中带粉的颜色。然后我姐姐珍妮特穿的是蓝色。好吧，因为我们决定用宝石色调。是的。
We wrote them back and we said,
we'll be doing jewel tones with black slacks.
I know.
And you wrote that back.
I was like, they think we're crazy.
Jewel tones.
So once we figured out what to wear,
our family flew out.
我们回复他们说，我们会穿宝石色调搭配黑色长裤。我知道。而你回复了那个。我想，他们觉得我们疯了。宝石色调。所以一旦我们决定了穿什么，我们的家人就飞了
out to L.A. from St. Louis and Texas. I also want to share that my dad came along. He was in the audience on tape day, which was very special to me.
And we should also say who we were going up against. It was Scott Foley and his family. They were also nice, by the way. And we were absolutely termed by Scott Foley.
Well, you know, he's also from St. Louis. So we were all chatting St. Louis backstage. He took pictures with all of us.
My sister, Janet, was like, he is so handsome. Oh, my mom was swooning. I know.
I also want to mention there were lots of snacks backstage.
I always clock a good snack area.
Yes.
There was tea and coffee.
从圣路易斯和德克萨斯飞到洛杉矶。我还想分享的是，我爸爸也一起来了。录制当天他在观众席上，这对我来说非常特别。我们还应该说说我们的对手是谁。那是斯科特·福利和他的家人。顺便说一句，他们也非常友善。而且我们绝对被斯科特·福利迷倒了。好吧，你知道的，他也来自圣路易斯。所以我们在后台都在聊圣路易斯。他跟我们所有人都拍了照。我姐姐珍妮特直说，他太帅了。哦，我妈妈当时都神魂颠倒了。我知道。我还想提一下，后台有很多零食。我总是能注意到哪里有好零食区。是的。那里有茶和咖啡。
The folks at Family Feud took great care of us.
But my sister, Janet, maybe should skip the coffee because I looked over at her and you guys,
she had this glazed look in her eyes.
And I was like, are you okay?
And she was like, my heart is racing.
She said, literally, I can feel it beating outside my chest.
And then she proceeded to drink two more cups of coffee, which she never does.
So I think the coffee paired with her nerves of being on national television was not a great mix.
《家庭问答》的工作人员把我们照顾得很好。但我姐姐珍妮特也许应该跳过咖啡，因为我看了她一眼，大家伙儿，她眼神发直。我就问，你还好吗？她说，我的心脏在狂跳。她说，真的，我能感觉到它在胸腔外跳动。然后她接着又喝了两杯咖啡，她平时从来不喝。所以我觉得咖啡加上她要上全国电视节目的紧张感，简直是糟糕的组合。
I literally thought she was going to bounce right out of that green room.
Well, I was really nervous backstage, too, speaking of nerves, because my mom was telling stories about me as a little girl to like my hair and makeup people and any production assistants that came by.
And I was like, oh, my God, I hope she doesn't tell these on family feud.
I'm like in a semi spiral backstage.
my sister is cracking up. Emily seems so calm. Yes. She's a go with the flow person. And what was really cool was that they got to get glam treatment backstage.
And it was especially cool for my sister because, I mean, as a teacher, she does not get the fancy treatment that often. And so that was cool for me, too, to kind of treat them to a glow up.
Yeah. And it was also cool for me to get to give them like a little bit of an insider's look at what it takes.
to be on TV, you know? They were both like, wow, it's a lot of waiting. Yeah. But they also loved the
我当时真的以为她会直接从那个化妆间里蹦出去。好吧，说到紧张，我在后台其实也很紧张，因为我妈妈一直在向我的发型化妆师以及任何路过的制作助理讲述我小时候的故事，关于我的头发什么的。当时我就想，天哪，希望她不要在《家庭问答》里说这些。我在后台简直快要半崩溃了。我姐姐笑得前仰后合。埃米莉看起来很镇定。是的。她是个随遇而安的人。而且很酷的是，他们在后台享受了明星般的化妆待遇。这对我姐姐来说特别酷，因为，我的意思是，作为一个老师，她不常享受这种高级待遇。所以对我来说，能让他们体验一下焕然一新也很酷。是的。对我来说也很酷，能让他们稍微内部了解一下上电视需要付出什么，你知道吗？他们俩都说，哇，有这么多的等待。是的。但他们也很喜欢
snacks. Right. Yeah. Snacks and a glow up and lots of waiting. That sums it up. But then it was time to play.
I remember how we were lined up on stage. It was you first, then me, then your mom, then your sister,
and then my sister all the way at the end. And I was like, oh, I was immediately slightly worried
because whoever is at the end, they're the last one to guess when all the good answers have kind of been used up.
It's the hardest position in the line, for sure.
And she had had two cups of coffee.
But wait, do you remember backstage while they were lining us up?
We were like one minute to curtain or whatever.
零食。没错。是的。零食、美妆造型和漫长的等待。这就是全部了。但接着是时候开始游戏了。我还记得我们在舞台上是怎么排队的。你是第一个，然后是我，然后是你妈妈，然后是你姐姐，最后是我姐姐排在最末端。当时我就想，哦，我立刻有点担心，因为排在最后的人是所有好答案都被用光后最后一个猜的人。这绝对是排队里最难的位置。而且她还喝了两杯咖啡。但是等等，你还记得在后台他们给我们排队的时候吗？我们离大幕拉开或者别的什么只有一分钟了。
They were like 50 seconds.
Yeah, they're like, oh, you have to make a tableau.
You have to pose.
We're like a tableau.
Yeah, it's going to start in a shadow and you need to have a tableau.
the lights will come up on you.
Come up with something.
And we panicked.
他们说，还有50秒。是的，他们说，哦，你们得摆个造型。你们得摆姿势。我们就像，摆造型？是的，你们会从阴影中出场，你们需要摆个造型。灯光会在你们身上亮起。想个什么动作吧。我们慌了。
And the best thing that we could come up with was all of us resting our hands on our
chins.
Yeah.
With like a weird slight bend in our knees.
You couldn't tell what we were doing.
What were we doing?
Like the tableau and the shadow, it just looks like a bunch of people hunched over.
Yes, it was ridiculous.
我们能想出的最好的办法就是大家把手托在下巴上。是的。膝盖带着诡异的微屈。你根本看不出我们在干什么。我们到底在干什么？就像阴影中的造型，看起来只是一群驼背的人。是的，太荒谬了。
And then I remember like Scott Foley's team had this cool like Charlie's Angels thing.
Like some people's arms were up.
Some people were to the side.
We were just like leaning over.
We totally choked. We did. A little bit. It just all went by so fast. And then I remember, okay, lights are up. We're walking to our podium. Steve Harvey came out. The energy in the room was so amped. We start the game immediately. Like, you just dive right in. Yeah. And you were head to head with Scott Foley. I know. I had to go first. It was very exciting. I do also want to say Steve Harvey, man, like he's energy the minute he hits that stage. I know. And he has to be so quick on his feet. He's so quick. He's so quick. He's so,
entertaining. All of it was so fun, but let's hear our very first round.
All right, let's go, guys. Top eight answers on the board. We asked 100 women,
name something that would look good smeared all over your ex's car. Uh,
然后我记得斯科特·福利的团队有一个很酷的《霹雳娇娃》那种造型。比如有些人的胳膊举着。有些人侧着身。我们只是弯着腰。我们完全怯场了。我们确实是。有点。这一切发生得太快了。然后我记得，好吧，灯光亮了。我们走向领奖台。史蒂夫·哈维走了出来。房间里的气氛非常高涨。我们立刻就开始了游戏。就像，你直接就投入进去了。是的。而且你和斯科特·福利正面交锋了。我知道。我得第一个上。这太令人兴奋了。我还想说史蒂夫·哈维这人，他一上台就能量爆棚。我知道。而且他反应必须得极快。他太快了。他太快了。他太逗了，这一切都太有趣了，不过让我们听听我们的第一轮吧。好的，我们开始吧，伙计们。黑板上有前八名答案。我们问了100位女性，说出一个涂满你前任的车看起来会很好看的东西。呃，
condiments. Condiments. Quintamance. Whip cream. All right, Angela, we asked 100 women.
Name something that would look good, smeared all over your ex's car. How about some eggs?
Some eggs.
And darling, wonderful to have you here.
We ask 100 women name something
that would look good smeared all over your ex's car.
Paint.
Come on now.
调味品。调味品。调味品。鲜奶油。好吧，安吉拉，我们问了100位女性。说出一个涂满你前任的车看起来会很好看的东西。来点鸡蛋怎么样？一些鸡蛋。亲爱的，很高兴你能来到这里。我们问了100位女性，说出一个涂满你前任的车看起来会很好看的东西。油漆。来吧。
Now we're talking.
Black car, red paint.
Paint.
Emily, we ask 100 women, name something
that would look good smeared all over your ex's car.
Lipstick.
That's a school teacher.
We're gonna go to the other school teacher.
这话说得对。黑色的车，红色的油漆。油漆。埃米莉，我们问了100位女性，说出一个涂满你前任的车看起来会很好看的东西。口红。真不愧是学校老师。我们要问另一位学校老师了。
Janet, 100 women.
Name something, look good, smear it.
all over your ex's car, the kids are listening.
Crash marks.
You know, hammer marks, crash marks.
Janet, okay.
You're hammer marks.
Can't wipe them off.
珍妮特，100位女性。说出一个涂满你前任的车看起来会很好看的东西，孩子们在听呢。撞击痕迹。你知道的，锤子印，撞击痕迹。珍妮特，好吧。你的锤子印。擦不掉的。
Crash marks, hammer marks.
We got two strikes now.
We've got to be careful.
Foley family can steal.
Poop.
Fresh.
We've got two strikes now, Angela.
We've got to be careful again.
撞击痕迹，锤子印。我们现在有两个叉了。我们得小心。福利家族可以偷分。大便。新鲜的。我们现在有两个叉了，安吉拉。我们得再小心点。
Foley family can steal.
Talk to 100 women.
Name something might look good.
Smeared all over you.
your ex's car.
Your trash.
You're trash.
So then it went back
福利家族可以偷分。采访了100位女性。说出一个涂满你前任的车看起来会很好看的东西。你的垃圾。你是垃圾。然后又轮回了
to Foley's team. Yeah. To steal.
Yeah, but they didn't steal it.
So we got it. So we got it.
It's so funny
because my first instinct
was to say poop, but I was afraid
to say poop. Yeah.
And so I didn't say poop first.
福利的团队。是的。来偷分。是的，但他们没有偷分。所以我们拿到了分。所以我们拿到了分。太搞笑了，因为我的第一直觉是说大便，但我不敢说大便。是的。所以我一开始没有说大便。
But then when it came back to me, I'm like,
I got to say it. I mean, it's cold.
clearly going to be some sort of like poop or pee.
Yeah, for sure.
Did you hear my sister Janet leave her body when she said crash marks?
Yeah.
Camer marks.
You guys, she said that she just was thinking about like if you were mad, what would you do to a car?
但后来轮到我的时候，我想，我必须得说。我的意思是，这显然会是某种大便或尿液。是的，绝对是。你听到我姐姐珍妮特在说出“撞击痕迹”时灵魂出窍了吗？是的。摄像机印记。你们这些家伙，她说她只是在想如果你生气了，你会对一辆车做什么？
Yeah, of course.
She wasn't thinking about the item you put on top of it.
Of course.
She was thinking vandalism in general.
Exactly.
Yes.
But she said she was just like, time stood steel.
And those words came out of her mouth and then she was like, ah.
对，当然。她想的不是你放在它上面的物品。当然。她想的是广义上的破坏公物。完全正确。是的。但她说她当时觉得时间静止了。那些话从她嘴里冒出来，然后她就想，啊。
But anyway, what happened was, guys, then you go to the next round, which is like the main round.
And our team won enough points that we were in for the fast money bonus round.
Yes, this is when we got the chance to win up to $25,000 for our charity.
Yeah, because we'd already beat the Foley's.
We beat the Foley.
Sorry, Scott Foley and family.
You were lovely.
Yeah, we're so nice.
不管怎样，发生的事情是，伙计们，然后你们进入下一轮，也就是主轮。我们团队赢得了足够的积分，得以晋级快钱奖励轮。是的，这就是我们有机会为我们的慈善机构赢得高达25,000美元的时候。是的，因为我们已经击败了福利家族。我们击败了福利家族。对不起，斯科特·福利和家人。你们很可爱。是的，人太好了。
So here's how the fast money bonus round works for those of you who are unfamiliar.
I had never played it. So, I mean, I learned it that day. You have two family members who are selected
to play. One of you leaves the stage, right, where you can't hear. Yeah, you go to like a soundproof
booth. Yeah, that was me. I left the stage. So Jenna was going to go first. She was going to have
to answer five rapid fire survey questions. And then after Jenna answers, it's my turn. They bring me
out of this booth where I haven't been able to hear anything. And then I have to answer the same
questions as Jenna. But you can't say the same answer I said. Exactly. And we have to try to get up to
200 points. And that's how you win. I have to ask you, what was it like in the soundproof booth?
所以对于那些不太了解的人来说，快钱奖励轮是这样的。我从来没玩过。所以，我的意思是，我是那天现学的。你有两位被选中的家庭成员来玩。你们其中一个人离开舞台，对吧，去一个听不到声音的地方。是的，你到一个隔音间去。是的，那个人就是我。我离开了舞台。所以珍娜将第一个上台。她必须回答五个快问快答调查问题。然后在珍娜回答完之后，就轮到我了。他们把我从那个我什么也听不见的隔音间里带出来。然后我必须回答和珍娜相同的问题。但你不能说我和一样的答案。没错。而且我们必须努力获得高达200分。这就是你赢的方式。我得问你，隔音间里是什么感觉？
I've always wondered. You literally can't hear anything. Is it weird? I mean, you just stand there for a bit
by yourself. Does it feel like it's going on forever? No, not really. It didn't. I mean, because you only
got 20 seconds on the clock. That's true. So by the time I got back there, I mean, it was almost time for me to
come back out. It's funny, you feel like I had the tougher round, but I feel like you had the tougher round
because there were five answers that were now no longer allowed that you don't know. I just got to go
with my first instinct. Yeah, but you had 20 seconds and I had 25 seconds. And you know what we had to
hope for is that your brain and my brain don't think exactly alike. But if this podcast has taught
us anything, the odds were in our favor, lady. Well, let's hear my round and then hear your round.
我一直很好奇。你真的什么也听不见。感觉怪吗？我的意思是，你只是一个人在那里站一会儿。感觉像是永无止境吗？不，其实没有。并没有。我的意思是，因为你的计时器只有20秒。这倒也是。所以等我回到那里的时候，差不多就到了我该出来的时候了。很有趣，你觉得我的那一轮更难，但我觉得你的那一轮更难，因为有五个答案现在不能再用了，而你又不知道。我只能凭第一直觉来。对，但你有20秒，而我有25秒。你知道我们必须祈祷的是什么吗？祈祷你的大脑和我的大脑想法不完全一样。但如果这个播客教会了我们什么的话，那就是胜算对我们有利，女士们。好吧，让我们听听我的那一轮，然后再听听你的那一轮。
Okay.
Besides popcorn, name something people buy at a movie theater concession stand.
Soda.
Tell me how many TVs you have in the house.
Three.
Name a part of the body that people throw out a joint.
They're back.
Fill in the blank, cry blank.
好的。除了爆米花，说出一个人们在电影院小卖部购买的东西。苏打水。告诉我你家里有多少台电视。三台。说出一个人们容易扭伤的身体部位。他们的背部。填空，哭——。
Tell me the US state that starts with North.
Dakota.
Cry blank.
Cry baby.
Boom.
So then, Jenna, I guess they added up all your points, and you did really well.
But let's see how you did, lady.
Now, and also guys just know, I had to run, like, across this long stage to meet Steve Harvey on the front, and I was running in heels.
告诉我一个以“北”字开头的美国州。达科塔。哭——。爱哭鬼。轰。所以接下来，珍娜，我猜他们加了你所有的分数，你表现得非常好。但让我们看看你做得怎么样，女郎。现在，大家也要知道，我得一路小跑穿过这个长长的舞台去前面迎接史蒂夫·哈维，而且我穿着高跟鞋在跑步。
Okay, so just, I'm a little winded.
Okay.
Angela?
Yeah, that was a long way to run in heels.
Yeah.
Your bestie over there played the game.
She got out of 200.
What?
好吧，所以，我有点喘不过气来。好吧。安吉拉？是的，穿着高跟鞋跑那么远真不容易。是的。你最好的朋友在那边玩了游戏。她得到了200分中的。什么？
186.
That is so good.
Yo, you need 14 points.
I got this.
You ready?
All right, let's remind everybody of Jenna's answers.
25 seconds on the clock.
Okay.
186分。太棒了。哟，你只需要14分。我搞定这个。准备好了吗？好吧，让我们提醒大家珍娜的答案。计时器25秒。好的。
Here we go.
Okay.
Besides popcorn, name something people buy
at a movie theater concession stand.
Soda pop.
Try again.
Um, oh, chocolate.
Tell me how many TVs you have in the house?
我们开始吧。好的。除了爆米花，说出一个人们在电影院小卖部购买的东西。汽水。再试一次。嗯，哦，巧克力。告诉我你家里有多少台电视？
Four.
Name a part of the body that people throw out a joint.
Their neck.
Fill in the blank, cry, blank.
Me or river?
Tell me a U.S. state that starts with North.
North Dakota.
Try again.
四台。说出一个人们容易扭伤的身体部位。他们的脖子。填空，哭，空白。我还是河流？告诉我一个以“北”字开头的美国州。北达科塔州。再试一次。
Um, oh, Lord Jesus.
Jesus.
No.
North Jesus?
I was going, wow.
I ain't been paying attention in school.
Where's North Jesus?
Jesus.
嗯，哦，主耶稣。耶稣。不对。北耶稣？我当时想，哇。我在学校里根本没好好听课。北耶稣在哪里？耶稣。
We need 14 points.
Besides popcorn, name something that people buy
at a movie theater concession stand.
You said, chocolate, survey said.
Guys, our reaction to winning,
there's this great screen grab.
We're just like bare pile, like your mom,
your sister, my sister, we're like, ah,
我们需要14分。除了爆米花，说出一个人们在电影院小卖部购买的东西。你说的是，巧克力，调查显示。伙计们，我们获胜时的反应，有一个很棒的截屏。我们就像一堆人挤在一起，就像你妈妈、你姐姐、我姐姐，我们都在喊，啊，
it's like we won the Super Bowl.
I was so excited that we won,
and that we won the money for the charity.
It was just, it was awesome.
It was so much fun.
And lady, one of the things you and I talked about right after we filmed this was the pandemic.
Oh, it happened.
You're right.
就像我们赢了超级碗一样。我太高兴我们赢了，而且为慈善机构赢得了资金。这真是太棒了。太有趣了。而且女郎，你和我在这之后讨论的事情之一就是大流行。哦，发生了。你说的对。
Very shortly after.
In fact, I feel like when it aired, we were during the pandemic.
We were.
And we couldn't watch it all together.
Yeah.
We had wanted to do a viewing party.
And so your sister, so sweet, made us T-shirts.
Yes.
就在很短的一段时间之后。事实上，我觉得当它播出的时候，我们正处在大流行期间。我们确实是。我们没能聚在一起观看。是的。我们本来想办一个观影派对。所以你姐姐人太好了，给我们做了T恤。是的。
Her friend of hers that she works with did like a really cool piece of artwork of the five of us
standing behind the family feud like little podium.
Yeah, it's really cool.
And they put it on a t-shirt.
And instead, we all remotely had our viewing parties and we all wore our t-shirts.
Yeah.
That was really sweet.
Aw.
她工作的一个朋友做了一幅非常酷的艺术品，是我们五个人站在《家庭问答》小领奖台后面的画面。是的，真的很酷。他们把它印在了T恤上。相反，我们都在各自家里远程参加观影派对，而且我们都穿着T恤。是的。太贴心了。哦。
Well, Aunt, I loved reminiscing about that.
I hope y'all liked it.
But I think it's just the perfect way to start an Angela Kinsey birthday episode because she
loves her family and her friends and she loves to play games. And she especially loves to play tennis,
y'all. Which we will be discussing when we come back from our break.
Great. We are back. Lady, I'm going to kick off this section of the podcast with a little
trivia. Okay. You told me the movie and the song that were popular during my birth, month, and year. And so I'm
to do the same for you. The top grossing movie in the week of June 1971 was Love Story
好吧，安特，我太喜欢回忆那个了。希望你们大家也喜欢。但我觉得这绝对是开启安吉拉·金西生日节目的完美方式，因为她热爱她的家人和朋友，她喜欢玩游戏。她尤其喜欢打网球，各位。我们将在休息回来后讨论这个。太棒了。我们回来了。女郎，我要用一点冷知识来开启播客的这一部分。好的。你告诉我了我出生月份和年份时流行的电影和歌曲。所以我也要为你这样做。1971年6月那一周票房最高的电影是《爱情故事》
starring Ellie McGraw and Ryan O'Neill. That's the movie that made the name Jennifer so popular.
Her name was Jennifer, aka Jenny. That name blew up after that movie. The number one song
on the Billboard Hot 100 in June 1971. It was a double-sided hit by Carol King. One side was
it's too late and the other side was, I feel the earth move.
Oh, under my feet.
I love that song.
Yes, that stayed at the top of the charts for five weeks.
I also thought you might like to know that the number one television show was all in the family.
由爱丽丝·麦格劳和瑞安·奥尼尔主演。就是那部让“詹妮弗”这个名字如此受欢迎的电影。她的名字叫詹妮弗，也就是珍妮。那个名字在那部电影之后大火。1971年6月公告牌百强单曲榜上的冠军歌曲。那是卡罗尔·金的双面热门单曲。一面是《太迟了》，另一面是《我感觉大地在移动》。哦，在我的脚下。我喜欢那首歌。是的，那首歌在排行榜榜首保持了五周。我还觉得你可能会想知道，收视率第一的电视节目是《全家福》。
I love all in the family.
All right, lady, you love tennis.
You sort of formulated my birthday episode around my love of books, but I'm going to lean into your love of tennis.
So here's the thing, lady.
When you ask people to read a passage of their favorite book for my birthday, it just made my day.
But I didn't know, like, how do we honor this piece of you that is a tennis player?
Because we can't, like, all show you our favorite tennis clip.
That didn't seem fun.
我爱《全家福》。好了，女郎，你热爱网球。你某种程度上是围绕着我对书本的热爱来构思我的生日节目的，但我要顺应你对网球的热爱。所以事情是这样的，女郎。当你让大家为我的生日朗读他们最喜欢的书中的一个段落时，这简直让我的一整天都完美了。但我不知道，比如，我们该如何向你作为网球运动员的这一面致敬呢？因为我们不可能每个人都向你展示我们最喜欢的网球剪辑。那看起来并不好玩。
And none of us really know you as a tennis player.
In fact, you have often said to me, and I'm quoting you, Jenna, I am a totally different person on the
court. You've said this to me repeatedly. And I'm like, what does that mean? It's the side of me that
you and Sam don't know. Yes. Or Matt out there in San Francisco. Well, with your permission,
I reached out to your tennis ladies, as you call them. These are the women that you play tennis with.
This is Betsy, April, and Rebecca. Yes. You guys play like three times a week, right? Yeah. I mean,
we are traveling here and there. So we have other people that fill in. We also have a Sunday.
group that's amazing. Debbie and Frinsett and Julie, but my regular game is with April, Rebecca,
而且我们都不太了解你作为网球运动员的一面。事实上，你经常对我说，我引用你的话，珍娜，我在球场上是完全不同的人。你反复对我说过这个。我就想，那是什么意思？这是你和萨姆不了解的那一面。是的。或者旧金山的马特。好吧，经你允许，我联系了你的“网球女郎”们，正如你所称呼的那样。这些是跟你一起打网球的女性。这是贝茜、阿普丽尔和丽贝卡。是的。你们一周大约打三次球，对吧？是的。我的意思是，我们到处旅行。所以我们有其他人来替补。我们还有一个周日
and Betsy. And I gave you their information and I'm a little scared. Well, I reached out to these
ladies and here's what I asked them. I said, Angel has told me that she has a whole other side
to her that I don't know, that it's a competitive side that comes out when she plays tennis and that
you all have nicknames for her. Oh gosh. She has given me permission to do a little
digging and I was wondering if you could share a little bit about this other Angela that I don't know.
Oh, lady, they had fun with this. They got together, the three of them. Oh, my gosh.
Betz is in England. They got together on a Zoom and they recorded this message for you. I was laughing
so hard the whole time I was listening to this. So, okay, first of all, let's listen to how they
小组，超级棒。黛比、弗林塞特和朱莉，但我固定的搭档是阿普丽尔、丽贝卡和贝茜。我给了你他们的信息，我有点害怕。好吧，我联系了这些女士，我问了她们这样一个问题。我说，安吉拉告诉我，她有着我不了解的完全不同的一面，这是一个她在打网球时才会展现出的好胜的一面，而且你们所有人都有她的绰号。哦天哪。她允许我做一点深入挖掘，我想知道你们是否能分享一点我所不了解的另一个安吉拉。哦，女郎，她们对此玩得很开心。她们聚在一起，他们三个人。哦，天哪。贝茨在英国。她们在Zoom上聚在一起，为你录制了这个信息。我听这个的时候一直在哈哈大笑。所以，首先，让我们听听她们是怎么
described your tennis alter ego.
Okay.
So we're here to talk about our friend Angela and her tennis life, which is rich.
She basically, her whole life revolves around that.
I mean, her kids, obviously Josh, but the podcast, but it's mostly tennis.
If she could have her way, it would just be tennis.
Wouldn't you say?
Yes.
描述你的网球另一个人格的。好的。所以我们在这里谈论我们的朋友安吉拉和她的网球生活，非常丰富。她基本上，她整个生活都围绕着那个转。我是说，她的孩子们，显然还有乔希，还有播客，但主要是网球。如果能由她做主，那就只有网球了。你不这么认为吗？是的。
Absolutely.
Totally agree.
Yes.
And, and, you know, I think you put it really well, April.
There's a side of Angela you don't know unless you play tennis with her.
her. Well, yeah, that's right. So she'll, she'll show up to play tennis in the Angela that we all know and
love, right, where she like arrives and she has like a granola from Josh and some little gift for us and
some sweet story. And she's like, T-shirts made for everybody.
绝对的。完全同意。是的，而且，你知道，我觉得你总结得很好，阿普丽尔。安吉拉身上有一面，除非你和她一起打网球，否则你不会了解。哦，是的，那是真的。所以她会以我们大家都知道并喜爱的安吉拉的身份出现在网球场上，对吧，她到达时会带着乔希做的格兰诺拉麦片，还有给我们的小礼物和一些温馨的故事。她就像，给每个人定制了T恤。
She's sure. She brought me a hummingbird feeder and like, you know, like all these beautiful things.
Here's the new tea I have. You have to try it. The most considerate person ever.
Considerate.
Yes.
Literally like the kindest, sweetest, most considerate.
And then we get on the court, right?
She's like the Hulk.
She is.
她当然会。她给我带了一个蜂鸟喂食器，还有，你知道，所有这些漂亮的东西。这是我有的新茶。你必须尝尝。有史以来最体贴的人。体贴。是的。简直就像是那种最善良、最甜蜜、最体贴的人。然后我们上了球场，对吧？她就像绿巨人。她真的是。
There's a Jacqueline Hyde.
Yes.
But not like, she's not mean.
She's just really competitive in cutthroat.
So she has this shot and we call it the Angola.
Because it's a really good shot.
She's got a very good.
forehand and she has this shot where she does a really deep angle and it's very, very difficult to get to.
有双重人格。是的。但不是那种，她不凶。她只是真的很争强好胜、毫不留情。所以她有一个击球，我们称之为“安吉拉角度”。因为那是一个非常好的击球。她有一个非常好的正手，而且她有一个击球，角度打得很深，非常非常难接到。
And, you know, okay, that's fine.
And the first like three times she does it and scores points, by the way, when she's up, like,
like in the game we play, you know, the winner wins 11.
Like when her team is up like seven to, she's still doing that.
And that's what I get really mad.
I get mad at like three or four, I'll say.
I'm a little earlier.
And I'm actually mad.
And, you know, okay, that's fine. And the first like three times she does it and scores points, by the way, when she's up, like, like in the game we play, you know, the winner wins 11. Like when her team is up like seven to, she's still doing that. And that's what I get really mad. I get mad at like three or four, I'll say. I'm a little earlier. And I'm actually mad.|||And, you know, okay, that's fine. And the first like three times she does it and scores points, by the way, when she's up, like, like in the game we play, you know, the winner wins 11. Like when her team is up like seven to, she's still doing that. And that's what I get really mad. I get mad at like three or four, I'll say. I'm a little earlier. And I'm actually mad.
And I'll go, keep it up.
Keep it up, Angela.
Let's see where that gets you.
And I'm so clearly mad.
And she's like, he has no idea that I'm really mad.
It's like, I'm going to kill you.
Or the other thing she did to you, Rebecca, the little like,
Sometimes she's like a little tip of the hat
And I'll go, keep it up. Keep it up, Angela. Let's see where that gets you. And I'm so clearly mad. And she's like, he has no idea that I'm really mad. It's like, I'm going to kill you. Or the other thing she did to you, Rebecca, the little like, Sometimes she's like a little tip of the hat|||And I'll go, keep it up. Keep it up, Angela. Let's see where that gets you. And I'm so clearly mad. And she's like, he has no idea that I'm really mad. It's like, I'm going to kill you. Or the other thing she did to you, Rebecca, the little like, Sometimes she's like a little tip of the hat
and you're like, oh, don't do that.
It's like she'll do a really wicked shot
and then almost curtsy to you.
She does.
She has a little leg kick too.
She's a little like a leg kick.
When you're like, aren't you adorable?
We had to fill in for this woman
and you're like, oh, don't do that. It's like she'll do a really wicked shot and then almost curtsy to you. She does. She has a little leg kick too. She's a little like a leg kick. When you're like, aren't you adorable? We had to fill in for this woman|||and you're like, oh, don't do that. It's like she'll do a really wicked shot and then almost curtsy to you. She does. She has a little leg kick too. She's a little like a leg kick. When you're like, aren't you adorable? We had to fill in for this woman
who is only in town periodically
and she's Danish
and she is hilarious
because she curses in Danish.
and Angela hit two shots back to back.
One was in Angola, and then one was this really mean backhand drop shot.
Charlotte curseded her in Danish, and I have no idea what she said.
And I was on the same side of Charlotte.
who is only in town periodically and she's Danish and she is hilarious because she curses in Danish. and Angela hit two shots back to back. One was in Angola, and then one was this really mean backhand drop shot. Charlotte curseded her in Danish, and I have no idea what she said. And I was on the same side of Charlotte.|||who is only in town periodically and she's Danish and she is hilarious because she curses in Danish. and Angela hit two shots back to back. One was in Angola, and then one was this really mean backhand drop shot. Charlotte curseded her in Danish, and I have no idea what she said. And I was on the same side of Charlotte.
And I said, oh, my gosh, I'd love to know what you said.
And she was like, you really don't want to know.
And I was like, it's okay.
I was like, it's okay.
We cursed her in English all the time.
You can actually tell her what you said.
Angela.
Can you see it, Sam?
And I said, oh, my gosh, I'd love to know what you said. And she was like, you really don't want to know. And I was like, it's okay. I was like, it's okay. We cursed her in English all the time. You can actually tell her what you said. Angela. Can you see it, Sam?|||And I said, oh, my gosh, I'd love to know what you said. And she was like, you really don't want to know. And I was like, it's okay. I was like, it's okay. We cursed her in English all the time. You can actually tell her what you said. Angela. Can you see it, Sam?
I can absolutely see the curtseying thing.
I know exactly the leg kick in the hat tip.
Yep.
All of it.
But the hulking out, I can't picture.
What?
I mean, I'm always like purposes to win, right?
I'm here to win.
I can absolutely see the curtseying thing. I know exactly the leg kick in the hat tip. Yep. All of it. But the hulking out, I can't picture. What? I mean, I'm always like purposes to win, right? I'm here to win.|||I can absolutely see the curtseying thing. I know exactly the leg kick in the hat tip. Yep. All of it. But the hulking out, I can't picture. What? I mean, I'm always like purposes to win, right? I'm here to win.
Yes.
So what's the problem?
Yeah, I think they're looking for like a type of
sportsmanship. Where when you're ahead so far, you know, you do maybe a little bit of what I
off the gas. Yeah, you know, they call it like a gentleman's serve, right? Or like a, I know. Sometimes
I really do try to do that. And then other times you just see the court and you see the shot and you take it
and you forget that you're up seven to. You just see the shot. So you take it. I think it's fine.
You know? I'm on your side. Listen, you have to know. The two.
Yes. So what's the problem? Yeah, I think they're looking for like a type of sportsmanship. Where when you're ahead so far, you know, you do maybe a little bit of what I off the gas. Yeah, you know, they call it like a gentleman's serve, right? Or like a, I know. Sometimes I really do try to do that. And then other times you just see the court and you see the shot and you take it and you forget that you're up seven to. You just see the shot. So you take it. I think it's fine. You know? I'm on your side. Listen, you have to know. The two.|||Yes. So what's the problem? Yeah, I think they're looking for like a type of sportsmanship. Where when you're ahead so far, you know, you do maybe a little bit of what I off the gas. Yeah, you know, they call it like a gentleman's serve, right? Or like a, I know. Sometimes I really do try to do that. And then other times you just see the court and you see the shot and you take it and you forget that you're up seven to. You just see the shot. So you take it. I think it's fine. You know? I'm on your side. Listen, you have to know. The two.
people that influenced my tennis career. One was coach Lund in high school. He coached basketball. All he cared
about was basketball. We went to state and we won state for men's basketball. So this was a big legacy of his.
And then someone just told him, oh, and you also have to coach tennis. And he was probably like,
what the hell? Because he could give a shit. But he would drive me to matches. And right before I left
the van to go to my game, as I got out of the van, he'd say, Kinsey, victory or death?
That was it. Those are my only options. And then he would nap in the van and not even watch my match.
And then after the match, I'd get in the van. He'd be like victory or death. And if I said death, he'd say,
Stink and Kinsey. Stink and Kinsey. Okay, so you have Coach Lund. And then the biggest tennis
people that influenced my tennis career. One was coach Lund in high school. He coached basketball. All he cared about was basketball. We went to state and we won state for men's basketball. So this was a big legacy of his. And then someone just told him, oh, and you also have to coach tennis. And he was probably like, what the hell? Because he could give a shit. But he would drive me to matches. And right before I left the van to go to my game, as I got out of the van, he'd say, Kinsey, victory or death? That was it. Those are my only options. And then he would nap in the van and not even watch my match. And then after the match, I'd get in the van. He'd be like victory or death. And if I said death, he'd say, Stink and Kinsey. Stink and Kinsey. Okay, so you have Coach Lund. And then the biggest tennis|||people that influenced my tennis career. One was coach Lund in high school. He coached basketball. All he cared about was basketball. We went to state and we won state for men's basketball. So this was a big legacy of his. And then someone just told him, oh, and you also have to coach tennis. And he was probably like, what the hell? Because he could give a shit. But he would drive me to matches. And right before I left the van to go to my game, as I got out of the van, he'd say, Kinsey, victory or death? That was it. Those are my only options. And then he would nap in the van and not even watch my match. And then after the match, I'd get in the van. He'd be like victory or death. And if I said death, he'd say, Stink and Kinsey. Stink and Kinsey. Okay, so you have Coach Lund. And then the biggest tennis
influence in my life is my mom. My mother was amazing, amazing tennis player. I'll never be as good
as she was. And I just grew up watching her matches. And she has a very dear friend who,
who she played tennis with, who is from the Netherlands, Karina.
And her and Karina would say to each other before a doubles match,
stick it in their ear.
And so my mom will say to me before a match,
go stick it in their ear.
When I retell the story, I have to remember to really pronunciate ear.
influence in my life is my mom. My mother was amazing, amazing tennis player. I'll never be as good as she was. And I just grew up watching her matches. And she has a very dear friend who, who she played tennis with, who is from the Netherlands, Karina. And her and Karina would say to each other before a doubles match, stick it in their ear. And so my mom will say to me before a match, go stick it in their ear. When I retell the story, I have to remember to really pronunciate ear.|||influence in my life is my mom. My mother was amazing, amazing tennis player. I'll never be as good as she was. And I just grew up watching her matches. And she has a very dear friend who, who she played tennis with, who is from the Netherlands, Karina. And her and Karina would say to each other before a doubles match, stick it in their ear. And so my mom will say to me before a match, go stick it in their ear. When I retell the story, I have to remember to really pronunciate ear.
Because for a long time, my tennis friends thought I was saying,
stick it in their rear.
Okay.
Stick it in their rear.
So you hear it.
I hear it.
Anyway, so I have victory or death and stick it in their ear.
This is where I come from.
Because for a long time, my tennis friends thought I was saying, stick it in their rear. Okay. Stick it in their rear. So you hear it. I hear it. Anyway, so I have victory or death and stick it in their ear. This is where I come from.|||Because for a long time, my tennis friends thought I was saying, stick it in their rear. Okay. Stick it in their rear. So you hear it. I hear it. Anyway, so I have victory or death and stick it in their ear. This is where I come from.
This is as you step onto the court.
This is what's in my brain.
Well, that makes sense for this next clip, maybe.
Do you have it in your head even when you're warming up?
I guess so.
Even when you're warming up?
Why?
This is a leading question.
This is as you step onto the court. This is what's in my brain. Well, that makes sense for this next clip, maybe. Do you have it in your head even when you're warming up? I guess so. Even when you're warming up? Why? This is a leading question.|||This is as you step onto the court. This is what's in my brain. Well, that makes sense for this next clip, maybe. Do you have it in your head even when you're warming up? I guess so. Even when you're warming up? Why? This is a leading question.
I don't know.
Do you remember the injury?
Oh, no.
Let's hear it.
April, you're the only one here.
I think she's actually wounded.
I don't know. Do you remember the injury? Oh, no. Let's hear it. Oh, no. Oh, no. April, you're the only one here. I think she's actually wounded.|||I don't know. Do you remember the injury? Oh, no. Let's hear it. Oh, no. Oh, no. April, you're the only one here. I think she's actually wounded.
Yeah, I think so. I think so. And I'm going to add during a warm up, like during a warm up, not even, yeah, no reason to come at me with like that, that fierceness. But yet she did. So.
You didn't that, right? And she hit really hard. Like right into my eye. Yeah. Like there was like I could not get my racket up in time. And you gave you a black eye. Yeah. Yeah. She did.
she did do that and then after that like i think it was maybe your first time back after that or whatever
i was on her team obviously a little skittish and you know we were all like okay it's okay april and so you
you know if you're not the hulk then you're like i'm going to not hit it at april as much as i can
and if i do accidentally hit it towards you i it's oh my gosh i'm so sorry you know sort of an
understanding and the Hulk just kept coming back at you. Yes, she did. Yes, she did. It was more like
an opportunity to be scoring. The thing is amazing about her also is it's impossible to actually make
Yeah, I think so. I think so. And I'm going to add during a warm up, like during a warm up, not even, yeah, no reason to come at me with like that, that fierceness. But yet she did. So. You didn't that, right? And she hit really hard. Like right into my eye. Yeah. Like there was like I could not get my racket up in time. And you gave you a black eye. Yeah. Yeah. She did. she did do that and then after that like i think it was maybe your first time back after that or whatever i was on her team obviously a little skittish and you know we were all like okay it's okay april and so you you know if you're not the hulk then you're like i'm going to not hit it at april as much as i can and if i do accidentally hit it towards you i it's oh my gosh i'm so sorry you know sort of an understanding and the Hulk just kept coming back at you. Yes, she did. Yes, she did. It was more like an opportunity to be scoring. The thing is amazing about her also is it's impossible to actually make|||Yeah, I think so. I think so. And I'm going to add during a warm up, like during a warm up, not even, yeah, no reason to come at me with like that, that fierceness. But yet she did. So. You didn't that, right? And she hit really hard. Like right into my eye. Yeah. Like there was like I could not get my racket up in time. And you gave you a black eye. Yeah. Yeah. She did. she did do that and then after that like i think it was maybe your first time back after that or whatever i was on her team obviously a little skittish and you know we were all like okay it's okay april and so you you know if you're not the hulk then you're like i'm going to not hit it at april as much as i can and if i do accidentally hit it towards you i it's oh my gosh i'm so sorry you know sort of an understanding and the Hulk just kept coming back at you. Yes, she did. Yes, she did. It was more like an opportunity to be scoring. The thing is amazing about her also is it's impossible to actually make
her mad. Have you noticed that? And I try. That's a good point. Yeah, that is a really good thing.
Yeah. If you come back at her with the shots that she hits at you, she just will tell you good shot.
Oh, it's so irritating.
It's so irritating.
Oh, my gosh.
I'm sorry, I'm laughing.
So you busted this woman's face and then smelled blood in the water.
Okay.
her mad. Have you noticed that? And I try. That's a good point. Yeah, that is a really good thing. Yeah. If you come back at her with the shots that she hits at you, she just will tell you good shot. Oh, it's so irritating. It's so irritating. Oh, my gosh. I'm sorry, I'm laughing. So you busted this woman's face and then smelled blood in the water. Okay.|||her mad. Have you noticed that? And I try. That's a good point. Yeah, that is a really good thing. Yeah. If you come back at her with the shots that she hits at you, she just will tell you good shot. Oh, it's so irritating. It's so irritating. Oh, my gosh. I'm sorry, I'm laughing. So you busted this woman's face and then smelled blood in the water. Okay.
And then pounced on the opportunity.
First of all, one of the things they didn't mention, and ladies, how dare you, is that was a backhand.
It's really, my backhand is not great.
It's very inconsistent.
So I'm always like, I can't believe that was a backhand.
Like, that's your takeaway from the story.
Not I'm sorry?
I can't believe that one.
And then pounced on the opportunity. First of all, one of the things they didn't mention, and ladies, how dare you, is that was a backhand. It's really, my backhand is not great. It's very inconsistent. So I'm always like, I can't believe that was a backhand. Like, that's your takeaway from the story. Not I'm sorry? I can't believe that one.|||And then pounced on the opportunity. First of all, one of the things they didn't mention, and ladies, how dare you, is that was a backhand. It's really, my backhand is not great. It's very inconsistent. So I'm always like, I can't believe that was a backhand. Like, that's your takeaway from the story. Not I'm sorry? I can't believe that one.
But the thing they didn't mention is how impressive that is for a backhand.
For me.
But no, I, of course, I felt horrible.
And then a week went by.
And then April had a Shiner.
And I was like, oh, my God, April.
I'm so sorry.
I just felt so bad.
But the thing they didn't mention is how impressive that is for a backhand. For me. But no, I, of course, I felt horrible. And then a week went by. And then April had a Shiner. And I was like, oh, my God, April. I'm so sorry. I just felt so bad.|||But the thing they didn't mention is how impressive that is for a backhand. For me. But no, I, of course, I felt horrible. And then a week went by. And then April had a Shiner. And I was like, oh, my God, April. I'm so sorry. I just felt so bad.
And then the next time we played, it was the same shot, a backhand.
And I almost hit her.
again. And I was like, oh my God, that's it. I can't. I'm like, I didn't, you don't mean to hit someone
ever in tennis. Of course not. I mean, really, you don't. I mean, I think there's some people that
go at people on purpose, but I don't. I wish I had the accuracy. I don't. I mean, I don't wish that
I had the accuracy to hit someone. It's coming out a little. The Hulk is a little here. Also, do you know
what is really annoying is that now they're going to call me the Hulk and I'm so pissed. I now have a new
nickname. Well, lady, in addition to playing with your tennis ladies, you also started this year
And then the next time we played, it was the same shot, a backhand. And I almost hit her. again. And I was like, oh my God, that's it. I can't. I'm like, I didn't, you don't mean to hit someone ever in tennis. Of course not. I mean, really, you don't. I mean, I think there's some people that go at people on purpose, but I don't. I wish I had the accuracy. I don't. I mean, I don't wish that I had the accuracy to hit someone. It's coming out a little. The Hulk is a little here. Also, do you know what is really annoying is that now they're going to call me the Hulk and I'm so pissed. I now have a new nickname. Well, lady, in addition to playing with your tennis ladies, you also started this year|||And then the next time we played, it was the same shot, a backhand. And I almost hit her. again. And I was like, oh my God, that's it. I can't. I'm like, I didn't, you don't mean to hit someone ever in tennis. Of course not. I mean, really, you don't. I mean, I think there's some people that go at people on purpose, but I don't. I wish I had the accuracy. I don't. I mean, I don't wish that I had the accuracy to hit someone. It's coming out a little. The Hulk is a little here. Also, do you know what is really annoying is that now they're going to call me the Hulk and I'm so pissed. I now have a new nickname. Well, lady, in addition to playing with your tennis ladies, you also started this year
playing with USTA. Yes. Do you want to tell people about it? Yeah, I mean, I think you guys out there
probably know USDA. It's the United States Tennis Association, and it's really fun. And I'm at the
very beginning of this journey, but some ladies are really nice and some were total bitches.
And we all kind of commiserate after the fact of like, wow. Well, I met a very nice lady who played you,
I was in Tokyo and I was waiting for Lee and our daughter to get off of the 10th tallest roller coaster.
And a woman came up to me and she said, hi, are you know, are you Jenna Fisher from the office?
And I said, yes.
And she said, well, I just wanted to say that I played tennis with Angela Kinsey at USDA.
playing with USTA. Yes. Do you want to tell people about it? Yeah, I mean, I think you guys out there probably know USDA. It's the United States Tennis Association, and it's really fun. And I'm at the very beginning of this journey, but some ladies are really nice and some were total bitches. And we all kind of commiserate after the fact of like, wow. Well, I met a very nice lady who played you, I was in Tokyo and I was waiting for Lee and our daughter to get off of the 10th tallest roller coaster. And a woman came up to me and she said, hi, are you know, are you Jenna Fisher from the office? And I said, yes. And she said, well, I just wanted to say that I played tennis with Angela Kinsey at USDA.|||playing with USTA. Yes. Do you want to tell people about it? Yeah, I mean, I think you guys out there probably know USDA. It's the United States Tennis Association, and it's really fun. And I'm at the very beginning of this journey, but some ladies are really nice and some were total bitches. And we all kind of commiserate after the fact of like, wow. Well, I met a very nice lady who played you, I was in Tokyo and I was waiting for Lee and our daughter to get off of the 10th tallest roller coaster. And a woman came up to me and she said, hi, are you know, are you Jenna Fisher from the office? And I said, yes. And she said, well, I just wanted to say that I played tennis with Angela Kinsey at USDA.
And she's just the nicest person ever.
So just so you know, you did leave a very good impression at USDA.
I am nice, you guys. I am nice. I'm just there to win. And again, April, I'm so sorry about your eye and I love you. Before we start the call sheet questions, there was one thing. I was surprised the ladies didn't share, which is a lot of times when I do that little drop shot or the angle shot, they call me a cut. I think they were afraid to curse. But it's the highest form of praise. Like if any of us gets called that, we're like, thank you. Thank you for a mooch.
Uh-huh. All right. Yeah. In fact, we got Betsy a necklace. It looks like a gold charm, but if you get up really close, it says,
and she'll wear the necklace when we play. And when one of us does a shot, she's like, come kiss the necklace.
Well, Angela, I think now it's time to move on to the call sheet questions. This is special for your birthday.
And I'm very excited to hear your answers. All right. What was your first entertainment job?
All right. Well, we've talked about this a little bit on the podcast, but I've never shared, I think, this part, which is the very first time I was paid to act was during my improv days in my 20s. There was this guy who would put together improv groups to go into like corporate offices or corporate retreats. And lady, it was so awkward. It was so cringy. Like we would have to do improv games with like a sales team, you know, and try to incorporate whatever.
And she's just the nicest person ever. So just so you know, you did leave a very good impression at USDA. I am nice, you guys. I am nice. I'm just there to win. And again, April, I'm so sorry about your eye and I love you. Before we start the call sheet questions, there was one thing. I was surprised the ladies didn't share, which is a lot of times when I do that little drop shot or the angle shot, they call me a cut. I think they were afraid to curse. But it's the highest form of praise. Like if any of us gets called that, we're like, thank you. Thank you for a mooch. Uh-huh. All right. Yeah. In fact, we got Betsy a necklace. It looks like a gold charm, but if you get up really close, it says, and she'll wear the necklace when we play. And when one of us does a shot, she's like, come kiss the necklace. Well, Angela, I think now it's time to move on to the call sheet questions. This is special for your birthday. And I'm very excited to hear your answers. All right. What was your first entertainment job? All right. Well, we've talked about this a little bit on the podcast, but I've never shared, I think, this part, which is the very first time I was paid to act was during my improv days in my 20s. There was this guy who would put together improv groups to go into like corporate offices or corporate retreats. And lady, it was so awkward. It was so cringy. Like we would have to do improv games with like a sales team, you know, and try to incorporate whatever.|||And she's just the nicest person ever. So just so you know, you did leave a very good impression at USDA. I am nice, you guys. I am nice. I'm just there to win. And again, April, I'm so sorry about your eye and I love you. Before we start the call sheet questions, there was one thing. I was surprised the ladies didn't share, which is a lot of times when I do that little drop shot or the angle shot, they call me a cut. I think they were afraid to curse. But it's the highest form of praise. Like if any of us gets called that, we're like, thank you. Thank you for a mooch. Uh-huh. All right. Yeah. In fact, we got Betsy a necklace. It looks like a gold charm, but if you get up really close, it says, and she'll wear the necklace when we play. And when one of us does a shot, she's like, come kiss the necklace. Well, Angela, I think now it's time to move on to the call sheet questions. This is special for your birthday. And I'm very excited to hear your answers. All right. What was your first entertainment job? All right. Well, we've talked about this a little bit on the podcast, but I've never shared, I think, this part, which is the very first time I was paid to act was during my improv days in my 20s. There was this guy who would put together improv groups to go into like corporate offices or corporate retreats. And lady, it was so awkward. It was so cringy. Like we would have to do improv games with like a sales team, you know, and try to incorporate whatever.
like their company philosophy was, but then play like yes and games.
This was a thing.
Yeah.
I remember this.
This was like a big thing.
And as an actor, you could get hired to do these corporate retreats.
Yeah.
Team building.
like their company philosophy was, but then play like yes and games. This was a thing. Yeah. I remember this. This was like a big thing. And as an actor, you could get hired to do these corporate retreats. Yeah. Team building.|||like their company philosophy was, but then play like yes and games. This was a thing. Yeah. I remember this. This was like a big thing. And as an actor, you could get hired to do these corporate retreats. Yeah. Team building.
I mean, we went to one that was like way up like in the hills of Malibu at some retreat.
They were always super cringy because it's like all of a sudden I'm doing an improv game with like Bob from human resources.
And Bob thinks he's hilarious and he's trying to do bits and you're like, Bob, you're not yes-anding.
This feels like a real-life Michael Scott conference room meeting in a way.
Oh, 100%.
It's where you started.
It is.
Team building. I mean, we went to one that was like way up like in the hills of Malibu at some retreat. They were always super cringy because it's like all of a sudden I'm doing an improv game with like Bob from human resources. And Bob thinks he's hilarious and he's trying to do bits and you're like, Bob, you're not yes-anding. This feels like a real-life Michael Scott conference room meeting in a way. Oh, 100%. It's where you started. It is.|||Team building. I mean, we went to one that was like way up like in the hills of Malibu at some retreat. They were always super cringy because it's like all of a sudden I'm doing an improv game with like Bob from human resources. And Bob thinks he's hilarious and he's trying to do bits and you're like, Bob, you're not yes-anding. This feels like a real-life Michael Scott conference room meeting in a way. Oh, 100%. It's where you started. It is.
That's why they felt so familiar to me.
And then also I did a ton of commercials.
But my first paycheck for being in like a television show was the TV show step by step.
And I think I've chatted about it before.
Is this the wedding?
Yes, I found a clip of it.
Oh, let's hear it.
Okay, so you guys, to set it up, this is Season 7, Episode 12, titled Going to the Chapel.
That's why they felt so familiar to me. And then also I did a ton of commercials. But my first paycheck for being in like a television show was the TV show step by step. And I think I've chatted about it before. Is this the wedding? Yes, I found a clip of it. Oh, let's hear it. Okay, so you guys, to set it up, this is Season 7, Episode 12, titled Going to the Chapel.|||That's why they felt so familiar to me. And then also I did a ton of commercials. But my first paycheck for being in like a television show was the TV show step by step. And I think I've chatted about it before. Is this the wedding? Yes, I found a clip of it. Oh, let's hear it. Okay, so you guys, to set it up, this is Season 7, Episode 12, titled Going to the Chapel.
I got the part not because of my amazing acting talent, but because I was the exact same size
of one of the leads, Stacey Keenan, she played Dana, and we were both petite, had blonde
hair.
Hers was much shorter, so they made me wear a wig, lady.
And the wig looks ridiculous.
Carol, who was played by Suzanne Summers, thinks her daughter, Dana has eloped, and
crashes in on a wedding, and this is what we hear. Get ready to be dazzled, really, by this performance.
And so now, by the powers vested in me.
I got the part not because of my amazing acting talent, but because I was the exact same size of one of the leads, Stacey Keenan, she played Dana, and we were both petite, had blonde hair. Hers was much shorter, so they made me wear a wig, lady. And the wig looks ridiculous. Carol, who was played by Suzanne Summers, thinks her daughter, Dana has eloped, and crashes in on a wedding, and this is what we hear. Get ready to be dazzled, really, by this performance. And so now, by the powers vested in me.|||I got the part not because of my amazing acting talent, but because I was the exact same size of one of the leads, Stacey Keenan, she played Dana, and we were both petite, had blonde hair. Hers was much shorter, so they made me wear a wig, lady. And the wig looks ridiculous. Carol, who was played by Suzanne Summers, thinks her daughter, Dana has eloped, and crashes in on a wedding, and this is what we hear. Get ready to be dazzled, really, by this performance. And so now, by the powers vested in me.
Stop!
Stop the way!
You're not Dana. Or Rich.
No, we're Larry and Simone.
But thanks for running the most special moment of our lives.
Oh, gosh, I'm so sorry. Please, no, just forgive me.
And lots of luck.
There you go.
Stop! Stop the way! You're not Dana. Or Rich. No, we're Larry and Simone. But thanks for running the most special moment of our lives. Oh, gosh, I'm so sorry. Please, no, just forgive me. And lots of luck. There you go.|||Stop! Stop the way! You're not Dana. Or Rich. No, we're Larry and Simone. But thanks for running the most special moment of our lives. Oh, gosh, I'm so sorry. Please, no, just forgive me. And lots of luck. There you go.
Oh, first time on TV.
Thanks for ruining the best day of our lives.
Was your family so excited, though, that moment when they got to turn on the television,
and there you were, that they'd sent you off to Los Angeles,
and now you've come back through their television.
They were.
My mom was really excited because she loved Suzanne Summers,
and we had all watched all of her shows.
Oh, first time on TV. Thanks for ruining the best day of our lives. Was your family so excited, though, that moment when they got to turn on the television, and there you were, that they'd sent you off to Los Angeles, and now you've come back through their television. They were. My mom was really excited because she loved Suzanne Summers, and we had all watched all of her shows.|||Oh, first time on TV. Thanks for ruining the best day of our lives. Was your family so excited, though, that moment when they got to turn on the television, and there you were, that they'd sent you off to Los Angeles, and now you've come back through their television. They were. My mom was really excited because she loved Suzanne Summers, and we had all watched all of her shows.
A thigh master.
Oh, my gosh.
I had a thigh master.
Did you really?
Of course.
Did you not have a thigh master?
I didn't, but I think one of my sisters did because I remember seeing it sitting on the floor.
Yeah.
A thigh master. Oh, my gosh. I had a thigh master. Did you really? Of course. Did you not have a thigh master? I didn't, but I think one of my sisters did because I remember seeing it sitting on the floor. Yeah.|||A thigh master. Oh, my gosh. I had a thigh master. Did you really? Of course. Did you not have a thigh master? I didn't, but I think one of my sisters did because I remember seeing it sitting on the floor. Yeah.
But of course you had a thymaster lady.
Even back then, you were buying the gadgets.
People were like, doting for like how to like improve yourself.
If there was an infomercial, I bought it.
But this isn't about me, lady.
This is about you.
And I'm moving on to the second call sheet question, which is do you speak any other languages?
This is a three-parter, right?
But of course you had a thymaster lady. Even back then, you were buying the gadgets. People were like, doting for like how to like improve yourself. If there was an infomercial, I bought it. But this isn't about me, lady. This is about you. And I'm moving on to the second call sheet question, which is do you speak any other languages? This is a three-parter, right?|||But of course you had a thymaster lady. Even back then, you were buying the gadgets. People were like, doting for like how to like improve yourself. If there was an infomercial, I bought it. But this isn't about me, lady. This is about you. And I'm moving on to the second call sheet question, which is do you speak any other languages? This is a three-parter, right?
Yes, I made you answer all three.
Yeah.
So we're starting with.
Do you speak any other languages?
Which you guys all know, I speak Bahasa Indonesian.
And also a little bit of Spanish.
And a little bit of Spanish.
Quite a bit of Spanish.
Yes, I made you answer all three. Yeah. So we're starting with. Do you speak any other languages? Which you guys all know, I speak Bahasa Indonesian. And also a little bit of Spanish. And a little bit of Spanish. Quite a bit of Spanish.|||Yes, I made you answer all three. Yeah. So we're starting with. Do you speak any other languages? Which you guys all know, I speak Bahasa Indonesian. And also a little bit of Spanish. And a little bit of Spanish. Quite a bit of Spanish.
I mean, I can get around, yeah.
But I would say what I've retained the most over the years is Indonesian.
Okay.
Yeah.
Do you play a musical instrument?
I think I've mentioned this too, but I did not until we moved to Texas.
And I was the new kid from Indonesian.
I was a weirdo and I was trying to fit in.
I mean, I can get around, yeah. But I would say what I've retained the most over the years is Indonesian. Okay. Yeah. Do you play a musical instrument? I think I've mentioned this too, but I did not until we moved to Texas. And I was the new kid from Indonesian. I was a weirdo and I was trying to fit in.|||I mean, I can get around, yeah. But I would say what I've retained the most over the years is Indonesian. Okay. Yeah. Do you play a musical instrument? I think I've mentioned this too, but I did not until we moved to Texas. And I was the new kid from Indonesian. I was a weirdo and I was trying to fit in.
And my friend Shannon played the trombone.
And we were at a very small school.
And if everyone didn't participate, we didn't have a band.
So they were literally like, you want to play something?
Here you go.
So I played trombone.
Do you have a favorite book you've read?
Okay.
And my friend Shannon played the trombone. And we were at a very small school. And if everyone didn't participate, we didn't have a band. So they were literally like, you want to play something? Here you go. So I played trombone. Do you have a favorite book you've read? Okay.|||And my friend Shannon played the trombone. And we were at a very small school. And if everyone didn't participate, we didn't have a band. So they were literally like, you want to play something? Here you go. So I played trombone. Do you have a favorite book you've read? Okay.
So here's the thing I wanted to tell you.
It's not so much a favorite book I've read, but I have a genre that's my favorite.
And that is, I love to read a book.
that takes me somewhere else. Like, it needs to be an escape for me. It's harder for me to read things
that are likely to happen. So I like to be taken to a different time in history. I like to be taken to
a different country. For example, I loved a book and I'm rereading it. So I read this book a long time
ago. And recently I got a new bookshelf for my living room, you know, lady. And I now have a
real place to put books. So I started going through bins of books that I've had for a long time.
So here's the thing I wanted to tell you. It's not so much a favorite book I've read, but I have a genre that's my favorite. And that is, I love to read a book. that takes me somewhere else. Like, it needs to be an escape for me. It's harder for me to read things that are likely to happen. So I like to be taken to a different time in history. I like to be taken to a different country. For example, I loved a book and I'm rereading it. So I read this book a long time ago. And recently I got a new bookshelf for my living room, you know, lady. And I now have a real place to put books. So I started going through bins of books that I've had for a long time.|||So here's the thing I wanted to tell you. It's not so much a favorite book I've read, but I have a genre that's my favorite. And that is, I love to read a book. that takes me somewhere else. Like, it needs to be an escape for me. It's harder for me to read things that are likely to happen. So I like to be taken to a different time in history. I like to be taken to a different country. For example, I loved a book and I'm rereading it. So I read this book a long time ago. And recently I got a new bookshelf for my living room, you know, lady. And I now have a real place to put books. So I started going through bins of books that I've had for a long time.
And I came across Howard's End by E.M. Forster. And I had remember loving it when I read it a long time
ago. And I've started rereading it. Oh, wonderful. And I love it again. Just even how it starts is so
great with this letter from Helen. And I'm already like, oh, God, what's Helen got to say?
It's everything I love, lady. It's Edwardian society. You know, it's also talking about social
class and what the normal mores were at the time. And I don't know. I just love it. That is your wheelhouse.
You like that in movies as well. Yeah. I mean, your favorite movie, Pride and Prejudice.
Yes. Sounds very similar. Uh-huh. This is on brand for you, this book choice. It is.
All right. Number three, what's a place you've been to that you loved? Okay, so you did domestic and
And I came across Howard's End by E.M. Forster. And I had remember loving it when I read it a long time ago. And I've started rereading it. Oh, wonderful. And I love it again. Just even how it starts is so great with this letter from Helen. And I'm already like, oh, God, what's Helen got to say? It's everything I love, lady. It's Edwardian society. You know, it's also talking about social class and what the normal mores were at the time. And I don't know. I just love it. That is your wheelhouse. You like that in movies as well. Yeah. I mean, your favorite movie, Pride and Prejudice. Yes. Sounds very similar. Uh-huh. This is on brand for you, this book choice. It is. All right. Number three, what's a place you've been to that you loved? Okay, so you did domestic and|||And I came across Howard's End by E.M. Forster. And I had remember loving it when I read it a long time ago. And I've started rereading it. Oh, wonderful. And I love it again. Just even how it starts is so great with this letter from Helen. And I'm already like, oh, God, what's Helen got to say? It's everything I love, lady. It's Edwardian society. You know, it's also talking about social class and what the normal mores were at the time. And I don't know. I just love it. That is your wheelhouse. You like that in movies as well. Yeah. I mean, your favorite movie, Pride and Prejudice. Yes. Sounds very similar. Uh-huh. This is on brand for you, this book choice. It is. All right. Number three, what's a place you've been to that you loved? Okay, so you did domestic and
international. I did. So domestic, I would say, I just love nothing.
more than a road trip with Josh where we pack our snacks and one of my favorite ones we've
ever done is we went to the Redwoods.
The coastal Redwoods.
I mean, they're the tallest trees on earth.
They grow up to like 380 feet.
I just remember just being so amazed by them and humbled and I felt so small in the world.
And we did this really cool thing where we went zip lining in the Redwoods.
international. I did. So domestic, I would say, I just love nothing. more than a road trip with Josh where we pack our snacks and one of my favorite ones we've ever done is we went to the Redwoods. The coastal Redwoods. I mean, they're the tallest trees on earth. They grow up to like 380 feet. I just remember just being so amazed by them and humbled and I felt so small in the world. And we did this really cool thing where we went zip lining in the Redwoods.|||international. I did. So domestic, I would say, I just love nothing. more than a road trip with Josh where we pack our snacks and one of my favorite ones we've ever done is we went to the Redwoods. The coastal Redwoods. I mean, they're the tallest trees on earth. They grow up to like 380 feet. I just remember just being so amazed by them and humbled and I felt so small in the world. And we did this really cool thing where we went zip lining in the Redwoods.
I remember this.
You were nervous, though, because I don't like heights.
No.
But I love the Redwoods.
And I wanted to be game.
It was the whole family.
And they did this ropes course and I did zip lining.
And you are way high in the canopy of the trees going from tree to tree.
I remember this. You were nervous, though, because I don't like heights. No. But I love the Redwoods. And I wanted to be game. It was the whole family. And they did this ropes course and I did zip lining. And you are way high in the canopy of the trees going from tree to tree.|||I remember this. You were nervous, though, because I don't like heights. No. But I love the Redwoods. And I wanted to be game. It was the whole family. And they did this ropes course and I did zip lining. And you are way high in the canopy of the trees going from tree to tree.
It's so cool.
Wow.
I'll share in stories where we went.
That sounds like an amazing trip.
Yeah.
The noise of the world goes away for me when I'm in nature.
And I'm sure that's with everybody, right?
But it's just so wonderful.
It's so cool. Wow. I'll share in stories where we went. That sounds like an amazing trip. Yeah. The noise of the world goes away for me when I'm in nature. And I'm sure that's with everybody, right? But it's just so wonderful.|||It's so cool. Wow. I'll share in stories where we went. That sounds like an amazing trip. Yeah. The noise of the world goes away for me when I'm in nature. And I'm sure that's with everybody, right? But it's just so wonderful.
And you just take all the like emphasis off you.
and your life, and you're just surrounded by this wonderful, amazing creation.
It's funny that you say the noise of the world disappears for you when you're in nature,
and you sort of assume, like, you're like, of course, I'm sorry, like, yes, that must be everyone.
But I don't think that is everyone because the noise of the world disappears for me when I'm in New York City,
the noisiest place in the world.
There's something about confronting noise with noise relaxes me.
I get a little antsy out in the woods.
And you just take all the like emphasis off you. and your life, and you're just surrounded by this wonderful, amazing creation. It's funny that you say the noise of the world disappears for you when you're in nature, and you sort of assume, like, you're like, of course, I'm sorry, like, yes, that must be everyone. But I don't think that is everyone because the noise of the world disappears for me when I'm in New York City, the noisiest place in the world. There's something about confronting noise with noise relaxes me. I get a little antsy out in the woods.|||And you just take all the like emphasis off you. and your life, and you're just surrounded by this wonderful, amazing creation. It's funny that you say the noise of the world disappears for you when you're in nature, and you sort of assume, like, you're like, of course, I'm sorry, like, yes, that must be everyone. But I don't think that is everyone because the noise of the world disappears for me when I'm in New York City, the noisiest place in the world. There's something about confronting noise with noise relaxes me. I get a little antsy out in the woods.
Oh, so funny.
It's a little harder for me to relax.
And I know that about our friendship, too, because when we talk about what is our life,
like after our kids are up and out, where are we in the world?
You are always very nature-based.
Somewhere with lots of access to nature.
That's where I want to be.
And that's what you daydream about.
Oh, so funny. It's a little harder for me to relax. And I know that about our friendship, too, because when we talk about what is our life, like after our kids are up and out, where are we in the world? You are always very nature-based. Somewhere with lots of access to nature. That's where I want to be. And that's what you daydream about.|||Oh, so funny. It's a little harder for me to relax. And I know that about our friendship, too, because when we talk about what is our life, like after our kids are up and out, where are we in the world? You are always very nature-based. Somewhere with lots of access to nature. That's where I want to be. And that's what you daydream about.
Yeah.
And you love big hustle-bustle cities.
I know.
I'm like, will I live in London or New York?
Chicago.
Yes.
Tokyo now.
Yeah. Yeah. And you love big hustle-bustle cities. I know. I'm like, will I live in London or New York? Chicago. Yes. Tokyo now.|||Yeah. Yeah. And you love big hustle-bustle cities. I know. I'm like, will I live in London or New York? Chicago. Yes. Tokyo now.
Like, yeah.
Oh, well, I'll come visit.
Well, listen, I love nature.
I love that.
What's our limit, though?
Because maybe for me, it's like four days in a busy city with you.
Not with you.
It's the city.
Like, yeah. Oh, well, I'll come visit. Well, listen, I love nature. I love that. What's our limit, though? Because maybe for me, it's like four days in a busy city with you. Not with you. It's the city.|||Like, yeah. Oh, well, I'll come visit. Well, listen, I love nature. I love that. What's our limit, though? Because maybe for me, it's like four days in a busy city with you. Not with you. It's the city.
Yes.
Are you four days in nature?
Can you make it longer?
Four days sounds about right.
Right?
Yeah.
We'll keep it tight.
Okay.
Yes. Are you four days in nature? Can you make it longer? Four days sounds about right. Right? Yeah. We'll keep it tight. Okay.|||Yes. Are you four days in nature? Can you make it longer? Four days sounds about right. Right? Yeah. We'll keep it tight. Okay.
And then internationally, you guys, that was really tough for me because I grew up in Southeast Asia and so many beautiful places.
in that region feel like home to me.
And I love dearly, like deep in my core.
I love that part of the world.
And I couldn't pick just one.
So I decided to pick a place and part of the world that I had never been and was totally
foreign to me.
And it blew me away.
And then internationally, you guys, that was really tough for me because I grew up in Southeast Asia and so many beautiful places. in that region feel like home to me. And I love dearly, like deep in my core. I love that part of the world. And I couldn't pick just one. So I decided to pick a place and part of the world that I had never been and was totally foreign to me. And it blew me away.|||And then internationally, you guys, that was really tough for me because I grew up in Southeast Asia and so many beautiful places. in that region feel like home to me. And I love dearly, like deep in my core. I love that part of the world. And I couldn't pick just one. So I decided to pick a place and part of the world that I had never been and was totally foreign to me. And it blew me away.
And that is Iceland.
Let me tell you, if you love nature, if you love hikes, if you love waterfalls, if you
want to meet some of the nicest people in the world, go to Iceland.
We went to so many beautiful.
places there. I'll shout out one waterfall because it's one of my favorite family photos from the trip.
It's Skogafas, if I'm saying that correctly. It's like 60 meters tall. It's 25 meters wide.
It's like a full curtain. Imagine the most massive curtain of water that is just raining down
and you can kind of hike behind it and look at it. So you see the waterfall from the front,
And that is Iceland. Let me tell you, if you love nature, if you love hikes, if you love waterfalls, if you want to meet some of the nicest people in the world, go to Iceland. We went to so many beautiful. places there. I'll shout out one waterfall because it's one of my favorite family photos from the trip. It's Skogafas, if I'm saying that correctly. It's like 60 meters tall. It's 25 meters wide. It's like a full curtain. Imagine the most massive curtain of water that is just raining down and you can kind of hike behind it and look at it. So you see the waterfall from the front,|||And that is Iceland. Let me tell you, if you love nature, if you love hikes, if you love waterfalls, if you want to meet some of the nicest people in the world, go to Iceland. We went to so many beautiful. places there. I'll shout out one waterfall because it's one of my favorite family photos from the trip. It's Skogafas, if I'm saying that correctly. It's like 60 meters tall. It's 25 meters wide. It's like a full curtain. Imagine the most massive curtain of water that is just raining down and you can kind of hike behind it and look at it. So you see the waterfall from the front,
then you hike behind it and see it from behind. It's like you're inside.
the waterfall, and we saw it at sunset. So we were looking at the sunset through this curtain of
massive water. And like, we were wet. Like, we got drenched just from the spray coming off of it.
Wow. Iceland, guys. You loved that trip. I loved it. And it's only a four and a half hour flight from
New York City, lady. Mm-hmm. Look at this. I know. This is how we combine both our loves. I would go back
to Iceland in a second. We'll come spend four days with me in New York City. Hustle, hustle, bustle. And then we'll
head over to Iceland for four days. Nature! Yay! All right, lady, next question. What do you like to do
on the weekends? Well, I'm really simple. I just love to spend time in my backyard, especially in the
then you hike behind it and see it from behind. It's like you're inside. the waterfall, and we saw it at sunset. So we were looking at the sunset through this curtain of massive water. And like, we were wet. Like, we got drenched just from the spray coming off of it. Wow. Iceland, guys. You loved that trip. I loved it. And it's only a four and a half hour flight from New York City, lady. Mm-hmm. Look at this. I know. This is how we combine both our loves. I would go back to Iceland in a second. We'll come spend four days with me in New York City. Hustle, hustle, bustle. And then we'll head over to Iceland for four days. Nature! Yay! All right, lady, next question. What do you like to do on the weekends? Well, I'm really simple. I just love to spend time in my backyard, especially in the|||then you hike behind it and see it from behind. It's like you're inside. the waterfall, and we saw it at sunset. So we were looking at the sunset through this curtain of massive water. And like, we were wet. Like, we got drenched just from the spray coming off of it. Wow. Iceland, guys. You loved that trip. I loved it. And it's only a four and a half hour flight from New York City, lady. Mm-hmm. Look at this. I know. This is how we combine both our loves. I would go back to Iceland in a second. We'll come spend four days with me in New York City. Hustle, hustle, bustle. And then we'll head over to Iceland for four days. Nature! Yay! All right, lady, next question. What do you like to do on the weekends? Well, I'm really simple. I just love to spend time in my backyard, especially in the
morning. You know, the birds are chirping. I like to go check in on all my plants, see how they're doing,
see if anything needs attention, pruning, or, you know, I don't know. I just, it's my happy place. And
And I love it when Josh grills in the evening and the kids are all home and it's just kind of this giant happy chaos, you know.
And now that I play U.S.TA tennis, I usually have a match on the weekend.
So that's super fun too.
All right.
Last one.
Favorite midnight snack?
morning. You know, the birds are chirping. I like to go check in on all my plants, see how they're doing, see if anything needs attention, pruning, or, you know, I don't know. I just, it's my happy place. And And I love it when Josh grills in the evening and the kids are all home and it's just kind of this giant happy chaos, you know. And now that I play U.S.TA tennis, I usually have a match on the weekend. So that's super fun too. All right. Last one. Favorite midnight snack?|||morning. You know, the birds are chirping. I like to go check in on all my plants, see how they're doing, see if anything needs attention, pruning, or, you know, I don't know. I just, it's my happy place. And And I love it when Josh grills in the evening and the kids are all home and it's just kind of this giant happy chaos, you know. And now that I play U.S.TA tennis, I usually have a match on the weekend. So that's super fun too. All right. Last one. Favorite midnight snack?
I mean, who's up at midnight anymore?
Well, this is, we're using this as to mean favorite snack indulgence.
It made me laugh, though, because we've asked this question to so many people and they're all
like, who's up at midnight? And then when I read it, I was like, who's up at midnight?
I know. Here's the thing. I do have a favorite snack. And I probably, God, I don't know,
I don't have one every day, but probably, I mean, I have one almost every other day.
What is it? Lady, I take a piece of bread. Just one piece. I smear it with peanut butter.
Then I drizzle it with honey. Then I fold it on top of itself.
I mean, who's up at midnight anymore? Well, this is, we're using this as to mean favorite snack indulgence. It made me laugh, though, because we've asked this question to so many people and they're all like, who's up at midnight? And then when I read it, I was like, who's up at midnight? I know. Here's the thing. I do have a favorite snack. And I probably, God, I don't know, I don't have one every day, but probably, I mean, I have one almost every other day. What is it? Lady, I take a piece of bread. Just one piece. I smear it with peanut butter. Then I drizzle it with honey. Then I fold it on top of itself.|||I mean, who's up at midnight anymore? Well, this is, we're using this as to mean favorite snack indulgence. It made me laugh, though, because we've asked this question to so many people and they're all like, who's up at midnight? And then when I read it, I was like, who's up at midnight? I know. Here's the thing. I do have a favorite snack. And I probably, God, I don't know, I don't have one every day, but probably, I mean, I have one almost every other day. What is it? Lady, I take a piece of bread. Just one piece. I smear it with peanut butter. Then I drizzle it with honey. Then I fold it on top of itself.
Oh.
And I love it.
Peanut butter and honey you sandwich.
Yeah.
And I just do half.
It sounds good.
I keep it civilized.
I just do half.
Oh. And I love it. Peanut butter and honey you sandwich. Yeah. And I just do half. It sounds good. I keep it civilized. I just do half.|||Oh. And I love it. Peanut butter and honey you sandwich. Yeah. And I just do half. It sounds good. I keep it civilized. I just do half.
I don't go crazy.
It's such a good snack.
It is a good snack.
You get a little protein in there, a little sweet.
Mm-hmm.
What time do you eat this snack?
Not at midnight.
Anytime I want.
I don't go crazy. It's such a good snack. It is a good snack. You get a little protein in there, a little sweet. Mm-hmm. What time do you eat this snack? Not at midnight. Anytime I want.|||I don't go crazy. It's such a good snack. It is a good snack. You get a little protein in there, a little sweet. Mm-hmm. What time do you eat this snack? Not at midnight. Anytime I want.
Anytime.
Yeah.
When it moves you.
10.30 in the morning, three o'clock in the afternoon.
Okay.
Mm-hmm.
You don't have a snack time.
I don't.
Anytime. Yeah. When it moves you. 10.30 in the morning, three o'clock in the afternoon. Okay. Mm-hmm. You don't have a snack time. I don't.|||Anytime. Yeah. When it moves you. 10.30 in the morning, three o'clock in the afternoon. Okay. Mm-hmm. You don't have a snack time. I don't.
Snack time.
is every, all the time.
Snack time is all the time.
I have a nickname called Snacks Kinsey.
You know this.
Yes.
So of course, Snacks Kinsey would say
Snack time. is every, all the time. Snack time is all the time. Snack time is all the time. I have a nickname called Snacks Kinsey. You know this. Yes. So of course, Snacks Kinsey would say|||Snack time. is every, all the time. Snack time is all the time. Snack time is all the time. I have a nickname called Snacks Kinsey. You know this. Yes. So of course, Snacks Kinsey would say
Snacks time is all the time.
That's right.
Put that on a pillow.
Put that on a mug.
All right, lady.
Well, that was your birthday segment.
How do you feel?
Yeah, I hope this was fun for you guys to listen to.
Snacks time is all the time. That's right. Put that on a pillow. Put that on a mug. All right, lady. Well, that was your birthday segment. How do you feel? Yeah, I hope this was fun for you guys to listen to.|||Snacks time is all the time. That's right. Put that on a pillow. Put that on a mug. All right, lady. Well, that was your birthday segment. How do you feel? Yeah, I hope this was fun for you guys to listen to.
I'm like, am I so boring?
I just like tennis and gardening guys and my friends and family.
Lady, you are not boring and I'm not going to let you call yourself boring on your birthday podcast.
This was fascinating.
Also, Matt, you were having some technical difficulties earlier, and I know you wanted to shout out a happy birthday to Angela.
Before we move on to break, you wanted to say something.
Hi, Angela.
Hi, Matt.
我说，我是不是很无聊？我只喜欢网球、园艺，还有我的朋友和家人。安吉拉，你一点也不无聊，我绝不允许你在自己的生日播客上说自己无聊。这太精彩了。还有，马特，你刚才遇到了一些技术故障，我知道你想对安吉拉说一声生日快乐。在我们休息之前，你想说点什么。嗨，安吉拉。嗨，马特。
Happy birthday.
Thanks, buddy.
You're so awesome.
I love working with you.
I was thinking how when you call, because we'll hop on the phone to chat here and there to work something
out, how your little iPhone emoji is like this bright flower.
It's a hydrangea.
They're my hydrangeas.
生日快乐。谢谢你，老兄。你太棒了。我很喜欢和你一起工作。我在想，当你打电话的时候——因为我们时不时会打电话来商量工作——你的iPhone小表情符号就像一朵鲜艳的花。这是一朵绣球花。那是我的绣球花。
Oh, there you go.
But that's always how I feel when I see your name lighting up on my screen.
I'm like, I'm excited and bright and just excited to chat with you and catch up and get down to work.
And it's just so great working with you.
I hope you have an awesome day and year.
and I'm hoping I can get you on the pickleball court at some point this year.
I will begrudgingly play pickleball.
There it is.
哦，原来是这样。但每当我看到你的名字在我的屏幕上亮起时，我总是有这种感觉。我会觉得，我很兴奋、充满活力，只是很高兴能和你聊天、叙旧并开始工作。和你一起工作真的很棒。我希望你今天和今年都过得超级棒。我希望今年能有机会拉你上匹克球场。我会很不情愿地打匹克球的。就是这样。
All right.
We'll see the angela on the pickleball court.
I don't know.
I don't know how to do the angela on the pickleball court.
Perfect.
I imagine how hard she would hit on a pickleball court.
Yeah, it's like a little ball, right.
I'm saying, could we, us four, get, you know, book a court?
好吧。我们在匹克球场上见安吉拉。我不知道。我不知道怎么在匹克球场上表现出安吉拉的样子。太完美了。我可以想象她在匹克球场上会打得多狠。对，就像一个小球，对吧。我是说，我们四个能不能，你知道的，订一个场地？
Let's go.
Sam, do you play pickleball?
I've never played before.
I'm ready.
Perfect.
Well, I'm going to.
Do you play, Matt?
I play.
走吧。萨姆，你打匹克球吗？我以前从来没玩过。我准备好了。太完美了。好吧，我打算。你打吗，马特？我打。
Okay.
We'll have to figure out how to divide up the teams because I've started playing as well.
All right.
Well, I don't want it to mess up my tennis game.
So I'm only going to play with y'all one time.
Mess up her tennis game.
Listen to that.
Mess up the timing.
好的。我们得想想怎么分队，因为我也开始玩了。好吧。嗯，我不想把我的网球技术搞砸了。所以我只和你们一起玩一次。搞砸她的网球技术。听听这个。把节奏搞砸了。
The ball bounces different.
The racket.
You know, come on.
Okay.
We had a lady who played with us and she left to go play pickleball.
And when she came back, we're all like, what happened?
She's terrible.
All right.
球的反弹不一样。球拍。你知道的，拜托。好吧。我们有一个女士和我们一起打球，然后她去打匹克球了。当她回来时，我们都问，发生什么事了？她太糟糕了。好吧。
Listen, why don't we take a break?
and then when we come back, we'll do a little Around the Town, a very special Around the Town in honor of Angela's birthday, as well as our office question of the week.
And I'm going to have a donut.
Great.
Okay, we are back.
It's time for Around the Town.
And this week we're going to dedicate our Around the Town to all of you guys that are getting married.
So many of you have sent us the most beautiful wedding, saved the dates and invitations, and we wanted to shout out a few.
听着，我们为什么不休息一下呢？然后当我们回来时，我们将做一个小小的“城市漫游”，一个为了纪念安吉拉的生日而特别制作的“城市漫游”，以及我们本周的办公室问题。我要吃个甜甜圈。太好了。好的，我们回来了。是时候进行“城市漫游”了。本周我们将把“城市漫游”献给所有即将结婚的你们。你们中的许多人给我们寄来了最美丽的婚礼请柬和预告卡，我们想对其中几份表示感谢。
Jenna, you said we should call this wedding around the town.
I did?
I don't remember that.
I said I thought this was very fitting because your favorite part of our mail is opening wedding invitations.
So this fit perfectly in your birthday episode.
I do get very excited.
Yes.
Every time I see a wax seal on an envelope, I set it aside for you.
珍娜，你说过我们应该把这个叫做婚礼城市漫游。我说的吗？我不记得了。我说过我认为这非常贴切，因为你最喜欢我们的邮件的部分就是拆婚礼请柬。所以这非常符合你的生日特辑。我确实非常兴奋。是的。每当我看到信封上有火漆印章时，我都会把它为你留下来。
Well, here's the thing, you guys, about opening these invitations and save the dates is you get to witness a moment of someone's joy.
Mm-hmm.
It's a joyful occasion.
and you get to be a part of it in a small way.
Exactly.
All right.
So first up, congratulations to Whitney and Alexander, who will be tying the knot in
Mount Pleasant Pennsylvania this summer.
好吧，各位，关于打开这些请柬和预告卡，事情是这样的：你可以见证别人快乐的时刻。嗯哼。这是一个快乐的时刻。你可以以微小的方式参与其中。完全正确。好的。首先，恭喜惠特尼和亚历山大，他们将于今年夏天在宾夕法尼亚州普莱森特山喜结连理。
Whitney included a note that said she'll be walking down the aisle to forever by Chris Brown
and that she will remember to take some mental pictures during her hectic wedding day.
She said that she knows 100% she has found the gym to her Pam.
Aw. And congrats to Gina and Brady, who are getting married in Las Vegas, Nevada.
They made their invite look like an airplane boarding pass. It's the cutest thing.
Aw. I know. And then Brady wrote us a letter saying how much his bride to be loves the office and loves office ladies.
He said their wedding day is a celebration of those everyday moments that turned into something extraordinary.
It's about laughter, loyalty, and finding your person, even if it takes a few awkward.
惠特尼附上了一张便条，说她将伴随着克里斯·布朗的《Forever》走向红毯，她会记得在忙碌的婚礼当天拍一些脑海中的照片。她说她100%确定她找到了属于她的吉姆（Jim）的帕姆（Pam）。噢。恭喜吉娜和布雷迪，他们将在内华达州拉斯维加斯结婚。他们把请柬做成了飞机登机牌的样子。这是最可爱的东西。噢。我知道。然后布雷迪给我们写了一信，说他的未婚妻多么喜欢《办公室》和《办公室女士》。他说他们的婚礼是对那些平凡时刻的庆祝，这些时刻变成了非凡的事情。这是关于笑声、忠诚，以及找到你的那个人，即使这需要经历一些尴尬的...
pauses, inside jokes, and perfectly timed one-liners along the way, mostly from the office.
He wrote this, as Michael Scott once said, I'm not superstitious, but I'm a little stitious,
and we feel a little stitious that sharing this with you just might bring a little extra magic
to our day.
We also want to send a big congrats to Lauren and Eric, who will be getting married this summer
at Red Rocks in Colorado.
Lauren said, office ladies played a very important role in their relationship.
We started listening on a road trip through Spain and always save the newest episode for our next adventure.
停顿、内部笑话，以及一路上恰到好处的单句台词，大部分来自《办公室》。他写道，正如迈克尔·斯科特曾经说过的那样，我不迷信，但我有点迷信，我们觉得有点迷信，把这个分享给你们可能会给我们的日子带来一点额外的魔力。我们还要向劳伦和埃里克致以热烈的祝贺，他们将于今年夏天在科罗拉多州的红岩剧场结婚。《办公室女士》在他们的感情中扮演了非常重要的角色。我们在穿行西班牙的自驾游中开始收听，并且总是把最新一集的节目留给我们的下一次冒险。
Because of the podcast, we've been to conventions, pop-ups, and have won two office trivias.
Wow.
Congratulations, Lauren and Eric.
And lastly, we're sending our love and congratulations to Josie and Hunter who got married in an intimate ceremony in Sorrentice.
Italy. They included a note to us that said,
As we celebrate our marriage, we're grateful for the things that brought comfort and joy along the way.
This podcast kept us company during long-distance drives and provided comfort during difficult seasons like our miscarriage.
Grateful for the joy you bring into our lives.
因为这个播客，我们去过大会、快闪店，还赢过两次办公室冷知识比赛。哇。恭喜劳伦和埃里克。最后，我们要向在意大利索伦托举行温馨婚礼的乔西和亨特送去爱与祝福。他们给我们附上了一张便条，上面写着：在我们庆祝婚姻的同时，我们感谢沿途带来安慰和快乐的事物。这个播客陪伴我们度过了长途驾驶，并在流产等困难时期给予了我们安慰。感谢你们带给我们生活中的快乐。
Well, congratulations all of you and to everyone who sent in your wedding invites.
We open them all and we look at them all.
So we can't shout them all out.
But believe me, we have shared in your joy and we're sending you our congratulations.
Yes, Jenna, and we love this so much from time to time.
We'll be doing a wedding around the town.
All right.
Now it's time for our office question of the week.
好吧，祝贺你们所有人和所有寄来婚礼请柬的人。我们把它们都拆开看了，也都看过了。所以我们不能一一感谢。但是相信我，我们分享了你们的快乐，并向你们送去祝福。是的，珍娜，我们非常喜欢这样，时不时地，我们会做一次婚礼城市漫游。好了。现在是本周办公室问题时间。
This one comes from Taiz in Brazil.
Taise says, I would like an honest response from both of you ladies.
Oh.
From all of the managers after Michael, which was your favorite?
and if you could pick an actor to take the position,
who would it be?
Love you, ladies.
Hmm. I know.
这个问题来自巴西的泰斯。泰斯说，我想听听两位女士的诚实回答。哦。在迈克尔之后的所有经理中，你最喜欢哪一个？如果你能挑选一个演员来担任这个职位，会是谁？爱你们，女士们。嗯。我知道。
Okay, I'm going to tell you who popped in my head.
Okay.
But I don't think he was a manager.
Is it Joe Bennett?
Because Joe is not a manager, but she was my favorite.
Okay, I loved Robert California.
Oh, yeah.
I just, when James Spader,
好吧，我要告诉你谁突然出现在我脑海里。好吧。但我认为他不是经理。是乔·贝内特（Joe Bennett）吗？因为乔不是经理，但她是我最喜欢的。好吧，我喜欢罗伯特·加利福尼亚（Robert California）。哦，是的。我只是，当詹姆斯·斯派德（James Spader），
and I would not choose anyone but James Spader,
when he came in,
there was like this energy shift.
Oh, yeah.
That was so fun to play with.
Like his whole vibe, his, his timing is cadence.
Yes.
Yeah.
而且我不会选择除了詹姆斯·斯派德之外的任何人，当他走进来时，有一种能量的转变。哦，是的。玩起来太有趣了。就像他的整个氛围，他的，他的节奏。是的。是的。
It was just fun.
It really spiced it up at a time when, you know, we were losing this person, you know,
this character.
This anchor.
Yes.
That, you know, the show had really revolved around.
And it was like, oh, what are we going to do?
And here comes this super interesting.
这太有趣了。在一个你知道我们正在失去这个人（你知道，这个角色）的时刻，它确实给节目增添了趣味。这个精神支柱。是的。这个，你知道的，剧集一直围绕着的核心。当时的感觉是，哦，我们要怎么办？然后这个超级有趣的、
nuanced, actory actor.
Mm-hmm.
So yeah.
And a really delicious character, Robert California.
Yes.
Yeah.
Well, I love Joe Bennett.
I just, everything Kathy Bates did.
细致入微、演技高超的演员就登场了。嗯哼。所以，是的。还有一个非常美味的角色，罗伯特·加利福尼亚。是的。好吧，我喜欢乔·贝内特。凯茜·贝茨（Kathy Bates）做的每件事我都喜欢。
And the same thing.
The minute she stepped on stage, I was like, whoa, electricity, you know?
Yeah.
I couldn't wait to just watch her do her thing.
Okay, so who would you pick, though?
Well, you know, I had a pitch for who I thought should come in to be manager
after Michael Scott.
同样的事情。她一踏上舞台，我就想，哇，充满电力的感觉，你知道吗？是的。我迫不及待地想看她大显身手。好吧，那你到底会选谁呢？嗯，你知道的，我曾对谁应该在迈克尔·斯科特之后担任经理有一个想法。
Who?
That I just thought would be kind of fun.
I thought Deborah Messing.
She's just so funny.
Yeah.
And I thought it would be a cool energy
and I thought it would be fun to have a woman as manager.
Do you know who I always wanted?
谁？我只是觉得会挺有意思的。我认为黛博拉·梅辛（Deborah Messing）。她太搞笑了。是的。我认为这会是一种很酷的能量，而且我觉得让一个女性当经理会很有趣。你知道我一直想要谁吗？
Wanda Sykes.
Oh, would she have been amazing?
So good.
She's so funny.
She would have come in there.
Oh, I would have loved to have had a scene between Dwight
and Wanda Sykes as manager.
She just would have handed him his ass on a platter.
旺达·塞克丝（Wanda Sykes）。哦，她会很棒吗？太棒了。她太搞笑了。她会走进那个房间。哦，我很希望看到德怀特和作为经理的旺达·塞克丝之间有一场戏。她绝对会把他的屁股打得落花流水。
Well, that was such a fun question.
Thanks so much for writing in.
Well, listen, before we go, lady, you were so generous in my birthday episode.
You made a donation to the Library Foundation of Los Angeles in my honor.
And I'd like you to know that a donation has been made in your honor.
Now, I know the charities that you already support.
And I wanted to support a place that made me think of you.
that I thought captured your spirit. And I'm going to get choked up when I think about it,
好吧，这是一个非常有趣的问题。非常感谢你们来信。听着，在我们离开之前，女士，你在我的生日特辑里太慷慨了。你以我的名义向洛杉矶图书馆基金会进行了捐赠。我想让你知道，我们也以你的名义进行了捐赠。现在，我知道你已经支持的慈善机构了。我想支持一个让我想起你的地方，我认为它捕捉到了你的精神。当我想到它时，我会哽咽，
but something about you that you have to know you to know is that you take a very active and
personal advocacy role in a lot of people's lives in your life, friends and family members.
I experienced this when I went through my breast cancer treatment, the ways that you
advocated for me and protected me in our workplace, but you do elements of this that go even
further. So I don't want to share your personal life, but let's say, for example, you have a
friend, English is their second language. When that friend fell ill, you went to those doctor's
appointments and you took notes and you called the insurance companies. You did that kind of work
to make sure that your friend was getting the best care.
但关于你的一点是，必须要了解你才能知道，那就是你在生活中的许多人的生活中扮演着非常积极和个人的倡导角色，包括朋友和家人。当我经历乳腺癌治疗时，我经历了这一点，你在我们的工作场所为我辩护和保护我的方式，但你在这方面的做得甚至更远。所以我不想分享你的个人生活，但比方说，例如，你有一个朋友，英语是他们的第二语言。当那个朋友生病时，你去了那些医生的预约，你做了笔记，你给保险公司打电话。你做了那种工作，以确保你的朋友得到最好的照顾。
You do that for so many people in your life all the time.
And it's really moving.
And there's an organization called CASA.
And what CASA volunteers do is they are trained to work as child welfare advocates and family advocates.
So they're not social workers.
It's a volunteer organization.
And they kind of go beyond what a social worker is able to do because
the social workers are stretched so thin.
你一直为你生活中的很多人做这件事。这真的很感人。有一个叫CASA的组织。CASA志愿者的工作是接受培训，担任儿童福利倡导者和家庭倡导者。所以他们不是社会工作者。这是一个志愿者组织。他们某种程度上超越了社会工作者的能力范围，因为社会工作者的工作实在太繁重了。
Yeah.
So a CASA volunteer will get matched with a family or a child, and they advocate for them
in a very personal and a direct way.
So they will sit in the courtroom.
If that child needs dental care, they'll find the dentist.
They will try to get that covered, however it can be covered.
They support them educationally.
Anything having to do with their physical or mental health, their safety,
是的。因此，CASA志愿者将与一个家庭或一个儿童配对，他们以非常个人和直接的方式为他们辩护。所以他们会坐在法庭上。如果那个孩子需要牙科护理，他们会找到牙医。他们会试图让这笔费用得到报销，无论通过什么方式。他们在教育上支持他们。任何与他们的身心健康、安全有关的事情，
their permanency goals. That's what these volunteers do. And that reminds me of you. And so a donation
has been made in your name to this organization. Thank you so much, lady. That means so much to me.
It's a great organization. I actually have a friend who works with them. I didn't know that you're making
a donation, but that's wonderful. And I really appreciate that. That's special. You know,
what are we here for if not to care for others and be kind? And, you know, we're all in this together.
We really are.
Yeah.
But lady, you do like real high effort work for the people you love.
他们的永久安置目标。这就是这些志愿者所做的。这让我想起了你。因此，已以你的名义向该组织进行了捐赠。非常感谢你，女士。这对我有很大意义。这是一个伟大的组织。我其实有一个朋友在那里工作。我不知道你在捐款，但这太棒了。我真的很感激。这很特别。你知道，如果我们不是为了关心他人和保持善良而来到这里，我们是为了什么呢？而且，你知道，我们都在这条船上。我们真的是。是的。但是女士，你确实为你爱的人付出了很多真诚的努力。
You know, you make the phone calls, you figure out the appointments, you go the extra mile.
Well, thanks, everyone.
Thank you so much for this birthday episode, you guys.
I just have had the best time.
I left you a message on the drive-in that I was so excited.
Well, I hope you feel celebrated.
Everyone, thank you for listening.
And we love you.
你知道，你打电话，你弄清楚预约的事情，你付出了更多的努力。好吧，谢谢大家。非常感谢你们带来的这个生日特辑，伙计们。我度过了一段最美好的时光。我在车上给你留了言，我太激动了。好吧，我希望你感到被庆祝了。大家，谢谢你们的收听。我们爱你们。
We'll see you next week.
Yeah.
See you then.
Thank you for listening to Office Ladies.
Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey.
Our senior producer is Matt Beagle and our audio engineer is Sam Pfeiffer.
Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis.
Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Schultz.
我们下周见。是的。到时候见。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》是Audience的一档节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的高级制作人是马特·比格尔，我们的音频工程师是萨姆·菲佛。Audience的执行制作人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。《办公室女士》由比尔·舒尔茨混音和母带制作。
Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton.
我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《Rubber Tree》。